(APPLAUSE) welcome.
Welcome to the library of
Congress. It's
the world's largest library. 84
-- 862 -- it's also
home to historyic recordings and
movies, and the
library of Congress for the
first time is
celebrating a very interesting
era in music.
I happen to live
through it.
And we had a
presentation on fashion and
the 70's and I kept saying that
is an oxymoron.
One of the best things
about living
through it and reviewing the
fashion and the record
recordings is we could have
crazy fashion because we
had such great music -- we were
all thinner because
we danceed all night, and we
really have cribbed, I
think in our generation and some
of my colleagues
that are here that liveed 32 it
too, the diverseity of
recorded sound. I would like to
greet live stream
viewers on stream and You Tube,
thank you for
joining us.
You'll here from a
range of distinguished
speakers, from music world,
academia, and broadcast
journalism. We're so thankful
for hosting this
wonderful -- including the
recording
academy, D DC
pride, and the silent dance
society, this program is
made possible by the support of
private donations,
we invite you to join us at LOC
.gov/disco to make a
contribution. We also ask you to
use the hashtag LC
disco.
Now for the first
session.
We are truly honored
to have a woman who
helped symbolize and create
something that we all
know
captures visually what disco
was about. You've
seen Yolanda baker on various
news and shows
recently, she is the only maker
of disco balls
through the United States,
through Louisville
national products, she has hand
crafted mirrored
disco balls for almost 50 years.
I think that
deserveed a hand.
(APPLAUSE).
Eo land da disco balls have been
all over
the word including at the edge
dare club 54 and
onset of the film Saturday night
fever which
celebrates its 40th anniversary
and happens to be
the library of Congress film
registry -- we
appreciate her participateing in
this symposium which
is very important in the
Louisville Kentucky native,
the Kentucky derbi.
We also are -- she has
worked with the
company since 1994 and will
share some things about
the hear of the mirror of the
disco ball. And then
-- she is a commissioner on the
district of Columbia
arts -- commission on arts and
humanity
, also a
attorney and realtor in
Washington D.C.
. In addition
she holds a degree of decorative
arts of design. So
let's give them a big library of
Congress disco
welcome.
(APPLAUSE).
Thank you so much.
Thank you, all for being here.
I'm going to introduce
sour speakers and
Tony is the service manager in
the mirror division
of Omega national product based
in Louisville
Kentucky. She's been an employee
there for 23 years
starting in 1994. Omega is the
premiere manufacture
of accessories as well as mirror
projects. This
includes disco balls Ann it's
mirrors. She loves
cooking, hiking and camping and
reading. She's an
avid fan of Louisiana individual
the 4th. She has
two grand daughters and one
grandson.
Yolanda baker is in
the mirror division
doctor she has worked for 49
years since
1968 --
(APPLAUSE).
She's an expert in the
manufacture being
of mirrored disco balls. She
also does quality
control for hand crafted mirrors
. She's been married
51 years for to her husband Tom
--
(APPLAUSE).
And has one married
son and two wonderful
grandchildren. She enjoys family
dinners, family and
andization,. Thank you for being
here on derbiday.
We're going to start with a
question -- Omega
national products makes some of
the best mirrors in
will world, can you give us a
little bit of an
explanation about its origin.
I can open help you
with that. We've been
making mirrors since 1946 when
the company was found
founded and it was made by hand,
hand crafted and at
that time most mirrors were.  We
no longer commute
mercury but we can make them on
antique mirror,
regular mirror, all from the art
democratic ohistory
ohistories of furniture and wall
covers and the best
thing to say is because we make
it in America,
because our company is so family
oriented we take
great pride in our work and
craftmanship.
Thank you, can you
explain the tie in in
1950's and democratic ofurniture
around desire for
everyone to have their furniture
ed mirrored?
We talked about this
above but a lot of
the very wealthy wanted all of
these replica
furniture pieces, and then it
was just a lot more
affordable to have it mirrored
rather than have half
of the solid wood and exotic
wood that came from
other countries. Then we had
some mirrored furniture
for tabletops and the art
democratic otables,
occasion a.m. tables, really --
I'm trying to think
-- I'm so sorry -- but I think
everybody loves to go
into the ring where it's expand
ed and when have you
a mirrored room, it just sort of
-- antique mirror
sort of takes away from some of
the mirrored image
and makes it a softer look for
people, and it's kind
of elegant and I think it shows
a richness.
Thank you. Now let's
get a little bit into
disco balls balls. Who wants to
explain to us the origin
of the disco ball?
It didn't start in
Louis individual
Kentucky, I can tell you that --
I really wish it
did but it didn't and we weren't
alive when it
started. It started over in
Europe and then in 20's
you can see disco balls in old
photographs of speak
easyies and ballrooms and
incorporating with the
tian
dehere's and then it came over
to America in the
early 20's but we didn't start
actually
manufacturing those until the 60
's. We were making
flexible wall covering and a
flexible mirror cover
covering and that's whateo land
da does, and a
company approached us and asked
if we would do
various sizes or unique shapes,
different kind of
substrates and that's when we
started making though
around 1960.
What was the largest
size of the disco
ball you've ever made and oddest
one.
I did a ten football
for Coke Cola, and
the oddest thing would be a
saddle.
And a four feet -- how
did you cover a
saddle? Did someone actually sit
on it?
It was for display in
a bar.
Wow.
I -- how you started
getting into making
them --
The company that
approached us and I don't
have that information but they
approached us because
we were making -- taking two
feet by two feet glass
sheets, they would silver them
and we would put a
glass -- went we started doing
that like cylinders
and different curveed walls
that's when the company
was approached, we were making
wastebaskets,
accessories, bathroom
accessories, and the company
came by and said we would like
to you mass produce,
and at that time there were
three people in this
department, one person covering
balls, one person
making the Self-s and one person
scoring the glass,
and those people grew into 28
people within five
years, making an average of 25
balls per person per
day. So at that time we really
became the most
revereed in America as far as
making disco balls and
they went global. No point
intended -- we make
mirrored globes because disco
balls were called
disco balls until disco. And we
still call them
mirrored balls today.
You still make
furniture as well now, and
antique mirrors and disco balls?
We actually make
the glass and sell it through
distribution, through
cabinet companies. I actually
have a disco ball desk
and credenza and I love it. I
said you can't throw
that away.
Can you describe how
you make a disco ball
ball?
You have a aluminum
shelf, it's hallow on
the inside, it has a hook on one
end, for the
hanging -- you take the
(inaudible) you put it
around the middle, fifty-five it
on there, and put
glue on the
ball -- it's that simple.
Simple she says. How
long does it take for
to you make one of these balls?
>> A 12-inch would
probably take about 15
minutes.
What was the longest
time it took?
The ten footer was
like two or three days.
Can you talk a little
bit about the trends
and the decorative arts in the
70's and 80's and how
the balls were involveed in
cultural?
I think a lot of
people could probably
tell us the same. If you can
remember like I can
remember in the 70's, you can
remember, we had
customers come in even before my
time at the company
company, they covered shoes with
disco ball material
material, we've had a bikini,
we've had just call
kinds of different shapes, like
she said, a lot of
companies wanted to brand their
product and catch
the eye of the public, and
everyone thought it was
so much fun. Every time you walk
into a ballroom or
a high school promise, anything
that was -- that's
from that day when you were
having the best time
with family, friends, everybody
's getting together,
dancing, who doesn't love to
dance? Seriously, who
doesn't feel happen when they
dance? I feel that
disco ball brought that wow
person out of them,
saying I'm going to uninhibited
right now and have V
fun --
And skating
relationships.
>> That's right. It's
all a lot of fun
when you think about a disco
ball. When someone's
hanging somebody wants to get
underneath there and
dance.
Was there
a specific movie that brought
our disco ball to start? John
tray Volta.
>> How did that happen
?
We had a New York
representative, and he
promoted our product for like
studio 54 and for
Saturday night fever. We know
soul train, the disco
ball was shared with Johnny
Carson's studio,
although I never saw it on
Johnnie Carson's show,
but yeah, I think that movie.
And also we have other
Vegas shows, that was a TV show,
we've had a lot of
movie and production companies
using it.
And you're the only
company now that makes
disco ball in the United States?
As far as we know
we've been the only
company, but we know of no other
retrodisco ball
manufacturer.
Where do companies get
disco balls if they
don't go to your company?
>>
Through distributors,
there's some in
Texas and New York.
>>
They would go oversees
as well --
Yeah, that companinged
our company -- once
they receiveed -- once over sea
companies learned how
to make a disco ball and more
checkly but not
efficiently they just swapped
quality or
for
quantity, which is is a shame,
helps us in a way
because they keep coming back --
although I had a
customer say I need a new disco
ball motivate tor--
when it's made by us it's going
to last.
Are there -- I think
of those big disco
balls with the stars coming out
of them -- how does
that work when have you some
famous movie star with
balls that open up, do you make
them open up? No,
the only thing I remember about
a star is Madonna
.
(APPLAUSE).
Riding on that big disco ball --
yeah,
that's what I was thinking --
and it didn't break?
No, I make them good. Wow.
What makes your balls
so unique? I think
it's because it is a retrodisco
ball. It is that
traditional disco -- you have
production companies
for movies, Vegas they have
their own production
companies that have made disco
balls with screens --
we make the traditional retro
disco balls.
Who is ordering disco
balls now? We have
believe it or not, restaurants,
we sell to
distribution, so we don't always
know where our
disco balls go. We did open up
some sales when NBC
came in and interviewed us
because there was a
strong interest -- Yolanda thank
has gained global
attention because everyone loves
her story, the
longevity, the fact that she
loves what she's doing
-- believe me, you cannot
imagine how fast she works
works. You can't imagine how
tedious she can be --
we make those clothes, she cuts
all the facets and
puts then on the globe and
they're beautiful, we
have colored gones, custom made
globes that have
sand blasted company names on
them it's tremendous
what she does, hang on to the
hooks, she's really
quite the craft person.
Thank you. You're
welcome.
(APPLAUSE).
You travel around the country or
go to
other seminars or on TV do you
run into other disco
ball that's you've made years
ago? Yeah, several
times
.
It's all inline, and
then the --
What is your
impression of how disco
culture influence the American
pop culture over the
years?
I think so too -- I think what
happened --
you probably all remember this
too -- for a while in
the 60's people weren't dancing
together, they were
doing all their thing, you can
dance all by yourself
yourself, when disco came back
in and the partners
and ballroom dancing, the
elegance of that and then
all of a sudden it got really --
you got gymnast
sticks in there, you really had
some talented people
come out and dancing and I think
it's a wonderful
art to watch.
Well, thank you. And
now it's time for a
surprise that Yolanda and Tony
have at the library
of Congress.
Dr. Hayden -- your partner in
crime.
The one I mentioned we didn't
coordinate this. But
we both knew what to wear. Great
minds think alike.
Oh.
Can you present it -- who's
office is this
going to go in? That's what I
asked. I -- do you got
it? A real Yolanda disco ball
with the library of
Congress on it. Yeah, it's --
that paint will
someday on there.
As you know I'll never
forget the belly
dance.
You can see the belly
dance. Where is it?
Right here. It's four piece
pieces together, it has
the cloth back, and we are
sharing this sort of
people want to come and see how
we make those. Can
you hold it? This is trying to
give you the old
disco feel.
Thank you so much. Do you have
it?
Well thank you for
having us.
Thank you so much.
And it's for those of
you that can't see it says
library of Congress with
a logo here -- with a little
insignificant kneea on
the side.
It's not that heavy --
I mean it's heavy
-- it's not that heavy. It only
weighs about 18
18 pounds. And Robert's holding
it. If.
And you'll be giving
demonstrations?
Giving demonstrations? On how to
cover a disco ball?
Well, we don't have any
materials with us, I'm sorry
sorry.
Okay, you don't want
to giveaway your
trade secrets.
Thank you so much. I
just want it thank
Yolanda and Tony for coming here
, once again on
their favorite day in Louisiana
ville Kentucky, the
Kentucky
derbi.
(APPLAUSE)
I thank all of you. As you know
this is just the beginning of
disco at the library
of Congress. So we hope you'll
participate in some
of the other programs today. And
I have to give a
sneak preview. I'll be changing
into different
outfits.
So, stay tuneed. Thank
you so much.
Hello everyone, it's
such an honor to be
here today in the presence of
the disco ball -- that
iconic center piece for
generations of us that were
danceing to.
What I want to express
particular pleasure
in the colors that sign through
in the fragmented
mirrored glass. I want to
reflect some of the way in
which the world's diverseity in
all the fragments is
reflected in it.
But first I want it
take a quick moment to
thank some of the people that I
couldn't be up here
without, particularly,wil who is
a former colleague
of mine, who does a lot of
interesting film work,
filming dancers around the world
and was very much a
part of this project, and all
the people working the
background, John doing audio and
vision, everyone
here at the library and Congress
-- and for the
invitation, it is an honor and
I'm humbleed for the
opportunity to speak here today.
Okay, about a third of
the ways through
her track hold up on her
fascinating
album released
about a year ago, Beyonce
emerges on a -- from a
scene on water on betrayal and
hopelessness. She in
turns with a stock voice over, I
try to change.
Close my mouth more, we hear the
weird sounds of
audio reverse and reverb en
companying this kind of
manifesto. Is it a baptism, is
it a drowning? Death?
Rebirth? Perhaps it's death
because she pro claims I
swallowed a sword. But then she
said immediately I
was baptizeed in the river.
As it shifts into
music two golden doors
open, perhaps a modern temple
and she enters the
music video as a singer -- water
no longer drowning
her breaks through the door
released like a rebirth.
Getting to the many levels of
what beian
say is doing is an extremely
difficult to do, her
works are increaseingly
sophisticated with endless
numbers of registers, this was
about a women's
journal of self-knowledge and
healing but they're so
to carebene practice practices,
motherhood, film,
literature, daughter's of the
dysin 1992, it indexes
so much of a bigger world, even
that
ro beta ca vel
velly dress, the Aruba goddess
of love and fertility
fertility. Mother in the sweet
waters in Nigeria.
Not only do we find
that reference in the
dress but also in her recent
appearance as a pretty
woman at the GRAMMYs. What the
dress signifyies is
the flowing water following the
great goddess of
place in the world, here
I want to show it in that
Nigerian region, she's on
the left where she's depicted as
a mirror made. On
the left our lady of charity as
the ocean goddess in
Havana, this was to celebrate
her 400 anniversary.
It's known to heal the
sick and bring song
and dance and fratilt and
prosperity. She is the
protector of the poor and mother
of all orphans. It
is clear that Beyonce say brings
down to her own
living legacy. In 2015 she
donated 7 million for the
apartments of a homeless shelter
in Houston --
provides drug screening case
management and so on,
and last month she initiated a
scholarship program
for student films, these are the
formation scholars.
But I want to draw
attention to something
else, there's more going on than
these realm
interventions.
Beyonce takes the mother's
susceptibility deeper -- we see
this in first two
baptisms and what's interesting
about this is she
focuses on the image as being
able to tell a story.
This is visual storytelling
instead of looking at
the lyrics we're looking at the
image gray. Images
one might say speak. And they
speak in ways that are
not catchable in words. What I
want to show today
it's not just images that speak
but also sounds,
sound and rhythms, they speak.
So I want to draw
particular attention to Beyonce
's ongoing perception
with African
rhythms -- these take us into
the
global framework for her music.
But let's go back a
few years, to that
moment in the middle of the
Obama years when beian
say was still rising in her
stature, ranging from
the Super Bowl to the singer of
the National Anthem
at the principle inauguration. I
want to play a song
from that period, to remind us
of that time.
(MUSIC)
.
I'll stop the song
there, to a striking
image where I'll return. In 2011
it was called run
the world girls. Musically
speaking we can talk
about
electric function, soul, and
elements of near
disco. The meaning of the song
is what perhaps is
least argued about, it is
official according to the
account of promoting female em
pourlett. In her words
I think of saying the things
that women want to say
but sometimes are not confident
to say, I'm going to
continue to write the song
that's give women
strength. And all the way across
of the spectrum,
there's a basic agreement that
this is about female
empowerment. It was also the
song that woke up the
final mission of the Atlantis,
and it initiateed a
period where I work of people
beginning to study
this phenomenal called Beyonce.
There was a syllabus
that connected her to black
message for social
change, and Beyonce say.
So the message of the
song seems quite
clear but let's go to the music,
what's going on in
the music?
And here, I want to
draw attention to the
fact that a couple of days ago I
gave a talk about
the way in which American music
from fun and soul to
mow town and disco and so on is
deriveed in large
measure from African music, pro-
african American
music and African
Caribbean, -- today I want to
tell
that story would call the social
life of a sound by
looking at some of the details
of Beyonce's song.
Let's start with
bell pattern --
Where does that come
from? It's a block
party invitation, a summons to
come to an event and
has that strange recorder Mickey
mouseing it. And as
the music enters it erupts into
the supreme being,
Beyonce is alive also drawing on
a standard cab ray
move.
But the track itself
is track upon the
floor from an album called guns
don't kill people,
lay sers do.
A white D J from floor
, and he is -- he
was first became more popularize
ed when he wrote
paper planes for MI A which is
the sock from slum
dog millionaire.
This was in 2010
before Beyonce decideed to
use it for the center track for
girls run the world.
To give you some
examples how it was
circulating -- here is the
rendition of it called
upon me.
(MUSIC)
.
Sorry to cut did T off
but we need to
cover a bit more ground. This is
directly related to
the typical sound to gentleman
makeian music, called
version or my colleague, Michael
calls the rhythm
method. This way there's a dance
track that
circulates among different D J's
and they repurpose
it in different contacts or rape
over it in
different ways.
The tradition of re
purposeing existing tech
technology, weather face the
turn table, had a long
legacy in Jamaica. I want to
push it further to 19
19th century, we listen closely
to the track, it
was -- it also had a drum
influence, and it was
probably mediateed by a D J
called after fro Jack,
and he was drawing on a dance
style. It's known as
ca check o, it's played at 45
beats per minute and
it has draws on the tradition
style inflected with
marching rhythms in the colonial
time.
This is interesting
because during this
time you had black bands playing
in military bands
as part of the colonial regime
but they shifted it
in a way to reflect their own
music. That's where it
comes in we might call it.
Here's a typical track
of the bubbleing
music -- and this is D J Chucky,
probably one of the
most prominent D J's.
(MUSIC)
.
Now let's go to
Johannesburg in South
Africa. Here I'm going to show
you a short clip
called real actions -- in this
case this is probably
our most group at the moment --
I'll tell you more
about them. Let's watch how they
move.
(VIDEO)
As you see, this is quite low
stepping but
quick low to etground kind of
urban street culture
that has origins in South Africa
-- quick steps steps
je
met federal lines -- the word
itself means to badel
like a duck, and if you move
like a duck you'll move
like flat footed tap and glide
with the buttocks out
out. Often dance moves follow
the metaphors of daily
life, called meta, meta, which
means putting butyron
bread.
Beyonce's coronograph,
she went across the
border to another
-- shaking the body. This is
another of what they're doing
and in some ways
looked down by being a
derivative itself.
Here is the connection
between what
Beyonce found on a You Tube clip
and then the
relationship that takes to the
corrography in the
video.
(VIDEO)
It's a slightly little different
referal but we'll get to that
the other one in a
minute.
(VIDEO)
Okay, I'm cutting it a little
short so we can get into this in
much more detail. I
want to show you one small
detail in the dance,
there's many different styles
some are called we
were style, there's few Tuesdaya
, and they're doing
more of the style where the arms
are wrapped tightly
around the torso -- this was
tricky and Beyonce say
had the
dancers felony out because they
couldn't get
the relaxed feeling together.
Real actions were not
that happy about this, they
thought that toe few,
toe few butyrtheir culture done,
that this was not
the original dance, they existed
a certain kind of
pride from someone as great as
Beyonce. But now I
want to make one brief -- what
about the imagery,
the bulls, the hyena and the
lion, where do they
come from? This striking scene
which is hidden from
the chain on her right hand,
it's the capital of
Georgia which was not
controversial because the
Israelis had just shut down that
region. What do the
has evenna's mean -- they're
like invocations of
advertising for colonial
European tourism back in
the days of Rhodesia.
One might say maybe
because they're
--
here's what he has to say about
them --
(VIDEO)
But the true reference is the ar
artis particular photo
journalism of Peter Hugo, a
South African photographer who
trophies people
around the world, blind people,
aids victims in
their cough minutes and so on.
This is edgey
photography and Beyonce say has
this imagery -- the
one you see here, performed with
hyena's and other
animals to entertain crowds to
make music with them
and sell traditional medicines.
Here's a few more
of these striking images.
What's interesting
about them in south
Africa there's been a long
history of critical
realism in South Africa
documentary that dates back
to the Bangladesh club,
photographers who were
involveed and go into dangerous
regions to take
photographers, Kevin Carter
committed suicide, he
took an image of Ethiopian child
, he found himself
in controversial and a few
months later he was dead.
Trying to private
advertise -- I approach
photographer with a keen aware
ness and pointing the
camera at anything.
Just to be clear a
year before the release
of girls return the world, there
was an exhibition
of permanent error, 2009 to 2010
which was driving
home the darker side, looking at
a picture -- where
he was looking at the way in
which digital circulate
circulates in the world, one of
the deep sadness of
digital life span, they begin in
Africa -- often
under very severe conditions and
find their way back
when we dump our waste back in
Africa. Here you see
the toxic waste dump where
people are trying to
extract living out of this
misguided policy of
shipping millions of tons of
obsolete materials in
that direction.
When his response was
raised, said he was
not sure if it fit N into the
song but felt the
hyena men might be looking for
conversation for some
of their efforts in that
production.
I want to make one
final point before
closing for today because it's a
purely musical
point, we spoke about the way
the drum that's were
brought in was referenceing this
ca lip so style, we
got to the African Caribbean
world, what you -- what
you find in the large scale
media, the next step,
where did that come from -- I
want to draw attention
to these pattern that's are
being drawn on that goes
like this --
forward pattern, if I put a
beat to it
would be something like this --
Okay -- that is very
strikingly, if you
speed up that pattern a little
bit you get precisely
that open track.
Okay. Now where does that sound
come from?
We know it as being associated
with the song -- I
want to return it back to the
origins which is back
in Africa, the way you feel that
pattern in Africa
is just a little bit different
-- instead of -- you
play it this way -- now you will
hear in some ways
all I'm doing is play ago
pattern a little bit more
slowly but in fact, I'm put play
ing it in a
different pulse -- if I'm play
ing this one and it's
going -- and the other one --
the one is going --
one two, one, two, one two, --
one two, three, one
two three, one two three --
one two three, one two
three, one two three, one two
three, and it's the
change or transformation of time
in three's to
benigny time that I would like
to note in my closing
arcs -- where does this pattern
come from? It's hard
to find a region in Africa where
it doesn't play a
role -- but I'm going to play
you one of the typical
bell pattern that's is associate
ed with a bell
instrument with two tones, and
is part of an
ensemble and here's the way in
slow motion that that
particular bell pattern sounds.
(MUSIC)
.
Seven strokes before
it begins again. One,
two, three, four five, six,
search one --
Okay, if I play a
second part, and I'm
going to have to demonstrate
this quickly -- here is
the bell pattern -- I play all
the spaces in between
that which is what your ensemble
will do --
That is what will become the
pattern as it
crosses over into the African
carebene.
Within this particular
ensemble it's
embedded. One way in which we
find a transformation
taking place is that instead of
adhereing that time,
we hear it in beanery time,
what's striking about
the African version is you can
hear that pattern in
any of many ways -- if I play it
again I'm going to
beat out different quote,
unquote drum beats against
it.
Or -- -- or --
Or --
Okay. What's interesting about
it is it's
organized in such a way that it
can train our bodybodys
in any of different time
signatures at the same time
time.
The structure of it is
long, long short,
long, long short -- a little bit
like the structure
of the white notes on the piano,
where you have tone
tone, half tone, tone tone tone,
half tone -- and
it's the ambiguity -- it's lost
when it moves over
into the African Caribbean and
begins something more
shoe honored in benignry time,
it's the small lust
when we look more depth into
what's at stake
globally into all these music
that's take us
sometimes to sad places such as
the toxic waste dump
site and the time signature
that's a little less
than it was in its origin. Okay,
thank you very much
much.
(APPLAUSE).
Hello?
Are you out there?
My name is bill Bernstein, I'm a
photographer, and I'm beyond
honored to be here at
the library of Congress in
Washington D.C..
And I wanted to thank
Dr. Hayden, I think
Dr. Hayden's here but thank you
for opening up the
library of Congress to this kind
of crazyiness.
It's refreshing, I
think.
I wanted to just talk
about my experience
with the disco culture.
I photographerred
disco from 1977 to 1979,
and
I was thrown into this culture,
I'll give a
little background about myself.
I was born in the 50
50's, I was one of the Woodstock
generation, the
first bug cultural phenomena
that I remember as a
kid is when the beetles came
over to the America on
the Ed Sullivan show and that
for me kind kind of
changed everything. I got a
musician, I got a set
oflag wig drums and played in a
rock band in high
school. I guess my culture as a
young man was kind
of the hippie culture, although
I wasn't a
full-fledged hippie, but that
was kind of where I
came from.
So, we were, you know,
anti-war, we were
mostly white, middle class, long
haired, suburban, a
lot of us, I got
tear gassed in the mallike
right
down the extrastreet here in
1970 when I was protest
protesting the war, anyway,
after I got out of
College I decideed to become a
photographer, and this
was in the 70's and the first
place that would hire
me I guess was the village voice
in New York City.
And this was in about
1976.
And so, I was
photographerring a lot of
street photography and portraits
thanks kinds of
thing. One night I was assigned
to go to studio 54
to photographerphotography
Jimmy Carter's' mother,
and I had never been to studio
54 before and I had
no interest in going -- I had a
curiosity but I was
not a big fan of disco music,
and at that time, my
rock station in New York over
night turned from rock
to all disco.
And a lot of people
were a little bit
confused and not happy with that
.
So I was he will well
aware of the fact
that disco was happening and I
saw Saturday night
fever which came out in 1977,
and it was a phenomena
that was occurring, and I
consider myself a photo
journalist, a portrait
photographer and a culture
anthropologist, I like to get
involveed in different
cultures, and look at them and
photograph them --
disco was its own culture.
I was sent to studio
54, and this is what
it looked like for me outside --
it was a very
difficult place to get into --
it opened up in 77,
and it was always -- they
started the vel vet rope
policy where people would stand
outside and be
chosen based on -- I'm not
exactly sure what -- but
I know if you were a celebrity
you had a good chance
getting in, I didn't all but you
had a good chance.
So this is what I saw
the first night that
I got there. And when I walked
inside this is what I
encountered.
And I never seen anything like
this
before -- when I was shooting on
the street or a
portrait I would have the person
all to myself, so
this was the word -- the word
paparazzi was the word
back in 1977 and here they are
and they're on top of
each other, to me, as a
photographer this was more
being a shot than what they were
shooting.
But that's what they
were shooting, that
ice Mrs. Carter, sitting next to
Andy war hole and
that's the shot that the village
sent me to get
which I got.
Then after the event
was over that I would
-- I would stay because I didn't
know if I could
ever get back in again.
So, I bought ten rows
of film from a
photographer, from one of those
guys, and I
basically hung out in the shadow
s up in the balance
doe, so I didn't get kicked out
and we waited for
the regular crowd to come in.
Put all the talk table
tables away abcleaned up and the
regular crowd came
in.
And, this is really
one of the very first
pictures that I took that night
in 77, this was in
December of 77. Studio 54 had
opened I think about a
month or two before that --
studio 54 was open from
77 to 79. Which is like -- two
and a half years,
something like that.
When I tell people
that they can't believe
it because they think it was
opened for ten years,
but it was a very, very short
period of time. When
it was owned by city and Erin,
who were the original
creates of studio 54.
This is the first
picture that I took
after you are took this shot for
the village voice.
And I was take this
picture, I think this
is the only real frame that I
got. I got a couple of
pictures of heme from the back
and then I asked if I
could shoot them and I shot this
and then went on to
shoot something else. It really
stuck in my mind
because it reminded me of a pre
war Berlin Cabernet
ray -- I remember seeing the
review Cabernet ray,
the gender biological weaponsing
, under tone, gay
earn tone, and
said omasochistic, a lot of
things
popped into my mind when I
photographerred this
couple. I started looking around
, this was later
that night, and I would see all
these images of this
prewar Berlin Cabernet ray sort
of thing.
This is a group that
was -- they came in
all together and through the
course of the night
they would dance together, guys
would dance with the
guys, sometimes the two guys
would sandwich the girl
on the dance floor.
I didn't know who was
who or what was what
with them, but they were like
this group that hung
out together. And there were in
this own little
bubble. And I kept an eye out on
them.
When they got on the
couch like this, I
was across the floor, I thought
that was an
interesting picture, so I sort
of hopeed I could get
across the floor with my camera
without them moving,
without them getting up and
leaving, which I did,
and I walked over and snapped a
couple of shots and
that was it.
And people can asked
me if this was posed.
It was not posed at all. They
were posing but not
for me. They were posing before
I got there.
And it's like almost
like they felt like
as I watched them that night
that they were the star
stars of the evening.
And they had this ora
about them, and they
were in this little bubble.
I those at the very
beginning when I went
to studio 54 not to photograph
celebrityies, it was
an early decision, and the
reason I did that was a
couple of reasons -- first of
all, everybody was
shooting at celebrityies, and
that's what
photographers were doing at
places like studio 54,
and they were all kind of
getting the same shot.
So I thought, if I
want to shoot a
celebrities, I want them in my
studio with myelitis
myelitissing and I want to talk
to them and interact
interact, and get a picture, get
something that I
want to get.
And not just sort of
snap a picture of
them sitting on a couch.
So I decided that I
didn't want to shoot
celebrityies, but I thought what
was more interesting
were the people that went there.
And the people who
liveed the disco life.
And I started to see things also
-- this looks like
a transgender woman with a sort
of straight Wall
Street banker type guy, and I
started to realize
there was something really
interesting going on at
disco -- I wasn't exactly sure
what it was -- it
wasn't Chris tall clear in my
mind but I felt
there's something really
interesting here from a
being frisk point of view and a
culture point of
view. And it was this freedom of
expression, this
openness, acceptness, inclusion,
I I've never seen
before -- what was happening was
-- what was
happening is during the 60's and
early 70's it was
the
women's right's movement, the L
GBT movement, all
of these movements sort of came
together at the same
time disco happened and disco
was the place for all
of these different movements to
go and have one
regular describe as a victory
dance.
So, they were all
there in union sen
having their victory dance.
I never seen anything
like this.
I'm coming from the
Woodstock generation.
If you go back and
stake a look at the
movie Woodstock, you can
probably counsel on one
hand how many African Americans
there are in the
audience. There they're all
mostly white, white hair
haired middle class kids. Most
of the entertainers
were African American or
Hispanic, but the audience
itself was not like this kind of
inclusion. You
didn't see that many transgender
s in the Woodstock
movie.
So, this was all
completely new to me --
it was just -- I was just -- my
eyes were bug you go
out of my head by what I was see
ing.
It seemed like a place
of freedom of
expression -- and be who you
want to be.
And it was young, old, and this
was a
particular interesting character
, named roller
regiona, and and she had this
gown, I guess it is --
and the glasses and the hat and
this magic wand, and
roll
roller skates.
And he was affix chew
in
green itch
village, you would see him all
the time roller
skating around and he would
bless you where his wand
wand.
And he was affix cure
at
the big discos,?
^ Is disco Sally. Who was I
believe in her mid-70's
-- she was a lawyer and her
husband was a lawyer and
her husband died and she was
left alone and heart
broken and never been to a disco
but some friends
said come on out let's go do
studio 54 and she went
and absolutely loveed it and she
became a regular.
People used to usually
young African
Americans or Hispanic muscular
young guys, she would
wrap her legs around them and
they would spin her
around.
Again, this is really
just the freedom of
expression. And
a safe place to be and a safe
haven.
This is a contact
sheet. I don't know how
-- I can't really see you people
, I don't know how
many people know what a contact
sheet is.
(APPLAUSE)
Yeah? Good. That's heatening to
know. When I started shooting
that's what we had to
deal with, I would go out at
night with my cannon A
1 and I would shoot with try axe
film, which was the
fastest film of its day, it was
400 A S A, I needed
fast film because these clubs
are dark -- I'm
looking out here now, some clubs
were dark as this
but there were flashing lights
so I would have a
moment to focus my camera but it
was a difficult
shooting situation that took me
a long time to
figure out.
But when I was
seriously shoot ago lot for
this project I would go out to
about 4 in the
morning and I would come back
and take my ten, 15
rows of film, I put it on my
table and I would go to
sleep and I would have an
assistant that would come
at 10 in the morning and develop
the film and hang
it up to dry and I would rise at
about 4 in the
afternoon and have a really
strong cup of coffee or
two and I would make a contact
sheet and sit and
look at it and see if I got
anything the night
before, because it's not like
being able to shoot
and look at the back of your
camera and say that's
good. You had to wait and look
at the contact sheet.
So that was the
process that I went
through to shoot. And honestly,
I don't miss it.
It's much easier to
shoot digitally.
Another thing -- at
the disco, in this if
I can time period was evolution
of the technology of
the sound system.
If you remember when the beetles
played at Shea stadium, the
sound they played, the
speakers they played through
were the bull horn
that's they would announce the
next batter, that was
the technology of the day.
Well, this is now ten
years later, and the
speaker system was incredible
and the mixing devices
and the amplifyiers were very
high tech. This is the
only female D J that I
photographed or found in New
York city during that period.
I'm not saying there
weren't others that I didn't
find but at one of the
major discos, this is the only
one, a place called
civil.
It's pretty much a men
's club, and I think
it still is to some extent today
although I met some
amazing female D J's in the last
few years, so
they're kind of breaking through
.
This is the speakers
-- I mean, they're
huge -- and this is -- this
would be one sort of set
of speakers here and in some of
the clubs they would
have these speakers lineing the
wall.
So, when they played
the disco beat, the
base especially, it would really
rock your insides.
And you would like get physical
high just, even if
you had done no drugs and walked
in off the street,
if you were standing in that
room for a while your
insides would start to shake and
you would get high
just from being there, so you
add the drugs and
alcohol to this and it was you
know, a pretty
amazing scene.
So, after studio 54, I decided
that this
is interesting. And I wanted to
see what else was
going on. This is 77, 78, I want
ed to see what else
was going on in Manhattan and
the five burrows. So I
went to 2001 odyssey where
Saturday night fever was
filmed. And it wasn't exactly
the most -- it was in
bay ridge Brooklyn, and it
wasn't exactly the up
scale Manhattan disco, it was
like a local disco.
This is the floor that
was in the movie.
It was actually built by Robert
stying wood and his
production people -- but it stay
ed in
2001 odyssey
after they left. And when the
building was torn down
sometime later, some private
collector bought this
floor, and I don't know where it
is, but somewhere,
probably in California, in L A
in somebody's
basement is this floor and he
has parties on
Saturday night.
This is really one of the most
famous club
clubs of its time. I don't know
if all of you know
of it --
(APPLAUSE).
This was agamassing
club, amazing club,
and I think -- those of who knew
about it then were
all over it but people are just
beginning to find
out about paradise garage, and
it had a couple
things going for it.
It was members club.
They didn't serve
alcohol, they serveed juice and
fruit. But people
brought their own poppers,
alcohol, and grass, and
it was plenty to get stoneed on
when you were there.
But the great thing
about this club, is
this guy.
(APPLAUSE).
Larryle van -- I don't have
enough time to
talk about him -- it's a whole
lecture in itself
because this guy -- this guy
really created modern D
J's in a lot of ways, and I've
spoken to a lot of D
J's today and everybody looks at
him as being pretty
much the imagine know survey tor
of a lot of
different styles.
And he played ever
kind of music that he
wanted tonight most of the clubs
they were handed
music by record companies and
say this is the great
hot one to play -- Larryy would
look at it and go,
I'll listen to it -- he would
play rock and roll,
rhythm and blues, month town --
pretty much
everything. I wasn't there that
night but one night
he really liked pat Ben tar song
love is a
battlefield, he liked that song
so he would play it
ten times a row, and he really
likeed it and he had a
way of hypnotizeing his audience
, they loveed him.
They used to calm him his play
ing Saturday mass.
They would go at Saturday mass,
started Saturday and
ended way late Sunday.
So, this volumes that
have been written
about him -- well worth reading
about.
This is what the dance
floor looked like
at pair dies garage.
Mostly Hispanic and
African American,
although, the thing about these
clubs is that if a
white person walk inside there,
if Austrians gender
woman walked in there, if
anybody walked in in it
with wouldn't have been a
problem, but most clubs
had their group but it had that
inclusiveness to it.
This was another one
of my most favorite
club that's a lot of people
never heard of it --
it's called give give's barber
room, it's where
twists started and after the
pepper ment lounge
closed it changed to
give give's bar -- they had
disco bats performing. It was a
mixed crowd. All
kinds of people went there.
There it is too.
And this is a picture
that sort of became
famous from my book.
It's -- this is a
transgender, pre-op
transgender named Ava, that I
saw so many times when
I went there that we finally sat
down and had a long
conversation. A middle class
Jewish boy like myself
sitting to a pre-op transgender
woman, it was an
amazing experience, and I just
learn address lot
just by doing this. It opened up
my mind a lot.
It became a place
where if you were out of
towner you would stop in and go
to this bar.
Another club called
Chris codisco.
Pretty much a gay club
but again, became
so popular that it became one of
those let's stop
there before we go home at 4 in
the morning. And
that can was the D J booth in
the back there.
I wanted to hit all of
these clubs. The
other club is the mud club.
A political applause.
This was considered
an anti-disco. They didn't like
studio 54. They were
political.
They didn't like the
commercialism. But it
became very, very popular and
they had a velvet rope
outside after a while too.
So, this is a famous
bathroom at the mud
club. I won't go into the
stories but just trust me
it's a famous bathroom.
This is a place called
hue ray's -- anti-
anti-disco. I went to roller
disco, it was big, it
was sweat and competition and a
lot of fun and if
you were a good skater, you
would put on your skates
and head out for the disco in
Brooklyn and showed
everybody your moves.
And again, it didn't
matter if you were
white, African American,
whatever, it was a
competition and it was fun.
I was a little nervous
going here because
it was a part of Brooklyn I
didn't know and it was
mostly African American, but the
miniwalked in I was
completely at ease and at home.
So, a couple of things happened
in 1979
that changed the disco scene.
And I sort of say
sometime that's it ended disco,
but that's not
exactly true and there's a
writer Tim Lawrence that
wrote about life and death on a
New York dance floor
about disco from the 80's -- I
think 80 to 83, and
he describes the fact that it
kept going and
creative and the disco that I
knew and experienced
in my opinion was over in 1979,
1980. The first
thing has happened was studio 54
, coke, spoon and
moon, they were closed down by
ICE, and IRS -- Steve
and an were skimming the cash
registers and taking
the money and putting it in the
ceiling panels of
the office. They would come down
every couple of
hours and take cash out of the
drawers. Steve would
wasn't the most sober person,
every time I saw him
he would go, who are you again
-- and I met him all
the time.
Bill Bernstein from
the voice -- oh, yeah.
So, Steve was being
interviewed and he
said, if the IRS knew how much
money we really made
they would shut us down.
And so, guess what
happened about two days
later?
And they went to jail.
And that place was
shut down.
It opened up under
some new ownership. To
me it was never the same.
There was culture
backlash against music,
culture, the rock and rollers
wanted their music
back and they got sick of disco
music and there was
a racial over tone to it that is
pretty much clearly
there but it was -- there was a
rarely over tone,
but
disco became unpopular, and
became sort of a
dirty word.
So, that happened.
And then, in I believe
it was 1981, the
New York Times published an
article saying that
there was an AIDS epidemic, and
that it was spread
spreading. And everybody knew
something was going on
-- they called it the gay cancer
, but they
officially declareed it an
epidemic, so what happened
was people didn't know anything
when AIDS was first
announceed, and so they were
afraid if you're talking
to somebody and they
accidentally spit a little and
it goes in your eye you could
get AIDSes or if they
were sweating and you touched
them or shook their
hand, so nobody knew anything.
There was no
information.
And Ronald Reagan came
into power at that
point and he didn't want to deal
with AIDS for the
first two years in office, his
administration. It
really affected the whole scene.
And those three things
in my opinion
really accounted for shutting
down or changing, I
should say, the whole disco
world that I knew.
Real quickly, what happened was,
these
pictures ended up in a box, have
somewhere, and they
ran in the village voice once in
a while but
basically I put them away in
1979, and in 2003 I got
a call from a guy named David
hill who is a producer
producer, he said there's a re
newed interest in this
period, would you like to do a
coffee table book, so
I said yeah, absolutely.
So he found a publish
er, real art press in
London, and Tony Norman and
David and I started put
putting this book together. And
-- this is 2015 -- I
railed realizeed as we were
doing this that it became
crystal clear to me what I had
here, because in 2015
the equal marriage amendment
passed, the mag, the
confederate flag came down in
the South, transgender
transgenders were allowed in the
military, it was
like this sea change during that
year of cultural
awareness and
acceptance and inclusion and I
thought
to myself what I captured here
was really like the
beginning -- like it was like a
small micro cosmic
of the world that we're
beginning to see today.
I feel that in
cultural movements like
this that you take two steps
forward and one step
backwards. And I think we might
be taking step
backwards right now a little bit
--
(APPLAUSE).
But I believe in my
heart that inclusion
and.acceptance is a natural way
of being as a human
being --
(APPLAUSE).
And I think we're going to move
forward in
our culture again. So thank you
very much.
(APPLAUSE).
Thank you.
Hi, my name is he will listen --
I wrote a
book called hot stuff -- and I
first of all, want to
thank the incredibly competent
staff here at the
library of Congress, they've
been appreciate.
I would like to linger
for a moment of
what I consider to be the irony
of this event, an
event that really Frankly seemed
highly, would have
seemed highly unlikely until
maybe even about ten
years ago, the idea that the
library of Congress
would be staging this event, un
thinkable.
(APPLAUSE).
For those of you who are too
young to
remember this, disco really
wasn't meant to be a
subject of books and films and
conferences where
participants would grapple with
its meaning and
affect. Disco was supposed to
have been buryied some
36 years ago. And it's actually
true that by 1981
all across America, road
stations were ditching
disco in any other format in
very many places across
the country, actual disco start
ed to shut down to be
replaceed by anything else.
In 1981, Grammy awards
drop it's
short-lived disco category after
it just established
it. Goryia Gaynor easy will Sue
has been the only
recorded awarded best disco
recording. Record labels
went about shutting down their
disco divisions if
they had one. And soon, the
record jackets of the
club single that's your D J
played, changed as well.
I was a D J in an arbor Michigan
--
(APPLAUSE).
So gone were the draw
ings of platform
shoes and all those other other
signifyiers of disco
and they were replaceed of
biographics that were
supposed to
create new ways. It had to be
rebranded
and hence, forth it you became
known as dance music.
But a funny thing
happened to the musical
gravy yard, disco percented --
persistented --
(APPLAUSE).
Thank you. This new
dance music employed a
last -- predictable beat but it
sounded an often a
lot like disco. Madonna, prince,
Michael Jackson cut
disco tracks, if if their record
companies avoided
ever calling it dais disco. Fast
forward today and
you tell me that Lauren green
white doesn't have a
look to disco.
Disco continues to
exact its avenge
through contemporary music and
events like today.
I would like to focus
on some of the
cultural work that disco did --
there is a paradox
that I think is at the heart of
the disco A it's
this. Disco in the classical
period was lyrical
liver slight. Even part of disco
could not argue
that its lyrics were especially
meaningful, get down
tonight, bookie down, and yet
disco pass ad cultural
and social -- it's at paradox
that it suggested to
me that sometimes music isn't
explicit political, it
might strike some as treat, can
never the less do
we are family -- it
was the song that could all get
people out on the
dance floor, but it was also the
song that kept
Nelson Mandela going when he was
in the prison.
I'm not knocking songs
such as Ohio and
public enemy and black steal,
but the a song may not
be political to get people
moving and even thinking
differently. What disco offers
us is a study in the
ways that music can be easyily
understand as a social
process. Through it we learn how
to experience our
own feelings, our own desires,
and sometimes our own
bodies.
And this isy why when
thinking music it's
important to acknowledge that
music not only reflect
reflects what's happening
politically
, socially, it
enacts change. And speaking of
change, I want to
turn to this first slide -- here
, I've quoted know
na Hendricks who was the
songwriter --
(APPLAUSE).
Who was a member of
patella bell and blue
bells and was the person within
that group who was
most strongly in favor
converting that group into
maremma law -- here's
is a girl group into something
far less conventional
conventional, more chaotic and
wild, but the same
could be same disco affected
listeners and dancers.
Let's hear a little
bit.
(MUSIC)
.
(APPLAUSE).
Yeah. You know, if you're
talking about
Beyonce say's feminism which I
think is a great
topic, you have to give I think
credit due to knowna
Hendricks and shacka can, you
have to give
properties to really props to
them because they are
among the most important
feminist voices of the 1970
1970's.
There are other people
that I have put up
here -- this is
hospitale rock the third -- the
wink
wink, wing, nod, nod, homosexual
personality which
was on a fair amount and front
an early disco group
and was the D J in Saturday
night fever.
(APPLAUSE).
He was a reluctant disco star,
he didn't
like disco initially.
And then of course the
village people.
And this was before
the village people
were quite processed, and quite
souple addictable.
I focus on these
slides disco artists who
are really unconventional but
it's important to
acknowledge a lot of critics and
listeners thought
that disco was regressive,
actually, they thought
disco was attacked for being too
gay and too
straight, too black and too
white, over sexed and
asexual,
leisure class -- and so, disco
for the
person who is trying to
understand and make sense of
it, it represented anything but
a stable sig five
fiveifier -- it was really a
moving target. How it K
that be? In my book hot stuff
which I called hot
stuff for several reasons, one
was there were two
book end songs -- I called it
hot stuff because I
wanted to discover disco's hot
ness, ending of racial
rules and gender and sexual
conventions. I argue
that disco broadened the contour
s in three areas,
first of all, disco evolveed out
of the the work of
African American musicians and
produceers who were
experimenting with lavish
significant --
sophisticated arrangement. So
much so, that some
critics and listeners thought
disco didn't sound
soul full or black. Secondly,
male sexuality shifted
with disco and gay men became
newly visible, largely
through the dissemination of
disco culture, it
shifted as a feminine si -- it
gives away to amotio
style to anyone who was
inaugural ball -- to the
village peopleFeminism critique,
remember the 1970's
the decade of -- critique of
three way sex -- I
shouldn't have to explain that
-- feminism of three
minute sex found its voice in
disco. It played
itself out with black female
performers who broke
with long standing
representational strategies that
Long before Madonna
put on those breastplates, this
had already been
done by Sarah dash in the center
.
When you're thinking
about representation
and obsession with respect
ability which is kind of
understandable, think of mow
town and the girl group
groups and their gowns and white
gloves -- so when I
think about disco, one of the
things I think is
important about it is that the
only way that you can
make sense of how we get from
Diana Ross in the 1960
1960's, to little Kim in the 90
's is to take on
board how disco validateed
female dire, the most
famously was Donna summers was
love to love you baby
baby.
I don't know what all
that noise is that's
out there.
So these changes that
I've outlined were
experienced as liberateing by
some but also
controversial, was disco a
reputation
of racial
profileing or turning A and B
music beige, was it
it best understood as
parody as conventional masculine
ity. Was it liberate
liberating of home homosexuality
or regressive and
stigmatizing of sissyness.
And what about women?
Disco filled the air
as one singer called women's
love rights -- this was
the social and legal policy that
would ensure a more
level playing field for women
lagged way behind the
sexual revolution.
Disco's promotion of
expressiveness seemed
to some people to run the risk
06 exacerbatesing women
women's vulnerability. And it
has to be said that
disco would not prove to be
anymore conducive of the
empowerment of female performers
-- here I'm working
about the working conditions.
I said I wanted to
talk in more specific
termings about the culture
cultural work and I want
to turn into the relationship of
gay men in
particular to disco.
Even before disco
became dices co, gay
male
sociability began to shift as
clear night light
was the
reverb ration -- it first
registered above
ground, rather than in exclusive
unmarked clubs
visible by only the lines out in
front of them. The
bars where these were most King
ly felt was a halfa
run dive in New York City called
the stonewall in,
of June 1969. It is said by many
, many historians
would agree, that it kick
started the gay liberation
movement in America.
Now scholars have
puzzleed over the
stonewall up rising, that it
happened when it did,
and that it seemed to trigger
this big movement.
Some historians argued
that at the time of
the rebellion, there was already
what was called a
active for almost two
decades, with a DC activists
being a leading figure
in it. Research has shown that
sexualmy norths had
taken to the streets before
stonewall, in one case
in L A at a bar -- others argued
if gaze and lesbian
lesbians were open to movement
make was because of
their participation in bar
culture.
I want to make a
different but related
argument, and it's what went on
outside the
stonewall in some 48 years ago
built on changes
already underway inside the
stonewall in.
The stonewall, was a
gay dancing bar. As
late of 1969, was unusual in New
York.
Most of the cityies
gale gay male bars did
not permit dancing while the
stonewall had two dance
floors. Testimony from stonewall
regulars you such
as the bar dance floors, the
room in the back which
was frequented by African
American and
Puerto Rico
street kids under mind the
sexual and impression,
the characterizeed other most
gay bars.
In the back room Judey
Garland was already
a thing of the past, as soul
music Blaired on their
jukebox, and the dancing there
was not too date.
The
culture that existed in the back
room articulateed
the desire of gay desire. You
can look across the
room, you could see a sexy guy,
you could infancy
size about getting involved but
you couldn't go over
and ask him to dance.
Another regular at the
bar credits the
stonewall with making him
confront his own sexual
tightness -- so the stonewall
was itself a site of
transformation, form ago strong
er connection of
going out and coming out.
Foraging a relationship
between cultureize edlysure and
what would become gay
liberation, and association that
disco would build
upon.
By the time music
writer Vince wrote about
what he called party music, in
the fall of 73, in
rolling stone magazine, gay men
have been dancing in
discos for three years, it would
take another year
before billboard magazine kept
track of hot dance
clubs as it called it, and two
more before the major
majors began taking the music
seriously.
When one considers the
cology text in which
gay disco took shape, dancing
had been restricted,
it's nearly impossible to dis
aggregate dancing from
politics, even if there had been
no D VJ's leading
dancers off the dance floor and
onto the streets to
protest -- this did happen in
New York City -- it
was still an act of defiance for
gaze and lesbian
beans.
With gay liberation would change
our
culture radically. It would also
turn gay social
socialability and gay
subjectivity, how they
understood themselves. As it
shift it from feminine
si -- how did disco participant?
First non-stop
music -- silence was not
tolerateed which is why
disco featureed the segways that
fooled you to
thinking you were dancing to the
last song, not the
new one.
A break with the past
-- a break with
those nights when a flashlight
or a red light
brought the music and danceing
to a halt.
.
And a good disco sound
system was like as
one person put it, an audio or
beganism --
The result that gay
men began fashioning
their bodies as dancing machines
. The owner of one
of man hat and's trendsingy
gay bars -- he said he
engineered the dancing bear
chested -- I quoted,
there was no A C and I made sure
the windows were
closed so it would heat up and
they had to take off
their shirts.
This practice of
dancing half naked
quickly spread.
What is that?
So, I'll keep talking.
Okay, much, much better.
That was definiteening
me and probably you
too.
Okay, so this buff
body, it was about file
file, but it was critical to the
recon figuring of
gay identity and desire. Before
gay men had been as
one person put it gay club --
hush puppiesers after
the same prey, rather than ally
ies or patterns -- now
gay men became the embodiment of
covetable masculine
masculinity, and infancy
advertising object of
desire for one another were
brothers, was the
feeling,
where are the men we've been
looking for --
not the trade that might beat
you up.
Now, I think the macho
turn is one of the
most sit and least study shifts
-- in his mol -- or
the -- this is his novel but the
narrator poppedders
that the possibility that the
macho look has taken
over, but it occurs to him that
maybe it's a send up
up, an a turn on, I would argue
that gay macho
operates in multiple registers
with the meaning
shifting according to context.
An author of a
wonderful blog, concedes
that the gay macho can be silly
in and of itself.
Gay men seem to behave more
decently toward each
other. Now what he identified
and I'm quoting as --
which had been so much a part of
sensibilities.
Others agree and point
to macho was
liberateing for the way it
challenged this automatic
association of homosexuality
with female anyone si.
At the time a number
of gay writers
question the
it was being achieveed. He had
mon white
warned our old fears of sys
sissyness -- are now locate
ed
through our persecution of the
transvestite.
The homosexuality was
destigmatizeed in
these years, it was at the
expense of a feminine si,
which was disavoid that the drag
queens that were on
the front lines were relegateed
to the margins of the
movement,
they would face harassment.
It did prove daunting,
particularly drag
queens found themselves shoveed
to the very sidelines
of gay life. Even gay's camp
style, the
identification like Broadway
musicals which
suggested that
transsend can't the strength to
endure the status quo -- now
that gay masculineity no
longer signaled -- and this
shift sideline, whole
categories of gay existence, as
many people came to
see antique in this new world.
This macho term was
participantly unapted
by gay --
Dennis atman, said our biggest
failure was
the inability to foresee the
extent in which a new
gay culture would emerge and
build on male/female
differences.
Another unapted result
of disco has to do
with class and race.
Now, no doubt, sub
cultures tend toward the
tribal. And the culture of gay
disco was no
about far to ready that
gay disco constituted entirely
this democratic --
but it is clear to me at least
that A list gay disco
discos, those that required a
good amount of money
to join, had a problematic
effect. I mean, it could
be very difficult to get passed
the doorman in
certain clubs, close to im
possible if you were a
women. Bet
mid-letter was denied --
So, you know, at the
same time, there was
the sense of brotherly love, as
I've indicated, it
had a distinct downturn. It was
the pull towards a
greater class and racial
homogeneity --
made for gay
club that's were increasingly
segletted along class
and race lines.
So the racial and
class crossings that had
for so long characterizeed gay
communeityies --
that
began to fade.
Something else I think
that gay liberation
liberationist didn't get quite
right with the
relationship of new gay commune
ityies toityies to commerce, as
it happens, the beneficiary of
-- it was not gay
liberation, it was the discos
and bathhouse that's
emerged that really became the
kind of glue for
communeity.
Now, despite discos,
the possible down
side, again that could be debate
ed, the commercialism
of disco culture, it was
nonetheless that gay men of
the 70's comarterred a course
that made them feel
was on the disco
dance floor, so many bodies
becoming one that gay
men created an sexual powerful
feeling of solidarity
solidarity.
What I say might seem
counter intuitive --
the
(inaudible) seems to enabled
communal aspiration
as Michael Warner has argued
rather than impedeing it
it.
When gay manmen began
to fall sick and die
of AIDS --
those discos became their real
support
communicationity.
And I'm going to end
here.
Thank you.
(APPLAUSE).
Hello everyone. I hope
everyone is getting
excited for the rest of today.
There's a lot of
awesome stuff going on and we
really appreciate you
being here throughout the
symposium. I'm one of the
produceers of museum. I come
from a conduct torFrench
horn player, art's administrator
pedigree, and it's
with great pleasure that we're
gathering here on
stage to do a bit of a
discussion and open it occupy
for your questions and we have
Martin anallis and
bill back on stage that have
given wonderful
lectures, giving a range of
different element that's
go into dance culture, from the
disco era and
--
I would like to ask
you where is disco now
compareed to where it was ten
years ago in terms of
culture memory?
In terms of cultural
memory? I think
everything has changed. One of
the things that I was
very struck by when I first
began writing about
disco, I think it was 1994, I
published an article
in the L A weekly, and oh my
goodnesses, some of the
letters to the editor were so
vicious. I was shocked
shocked.
And I was used to
disco hateers. Disco,
although I was a DJ, an arbor
was a punc town and
those lines were very much drawn
in the 70's and 80
80's. When my book came out in
2010 was an entirely
different environment, for the
most part young
people don't know about disco
phobia or when it was
the biggest cultural joke of the
20est century. So I
think everything has shifted and
disco permeates
popular music. Disco never died.
I think it's -- I
think it's entirely different
now, and to answer you
fully would take too much time,
but I think it is
true that in some sense the
culture wars in the U.S.
U.S., people usually focus on
abortion, let's say
affirmative action, but I think
the ER A in the 70's
and beyond I think disco was
very much a part of the
cultural wars.
Martin can you say on
disco and other
countries and how they're
similar or how they're
different?
Yeah, especially with
relation to the
contemporary question -- disco
changed and perhaps
out of some embarrassment
of character and so on and
associations with gay subculture
s and so on which
helped to marginalize it as kind
of a movement, but
then it begins transformed into
the dance music.
We can't imagine the
last 30, 40 music
without dance music being front
and center, whether
it's transmusic, house music,
and on and on, the
genre's pro-live rated in some
sense but disco
provided that moment for all of
it.
And the folks that I
mentioned in in my
presentation -- I might have
lost sound --
Yeah --
But the folks that I
mention inside my
presentation such as the music
in South Africa,
which is a music that's run on
automated digital
machinery, the technology that
came into the
mainstream at that point. The TR
33 drum machine for
example, is as being a place
where you can organize
rhythms using a different way of
interfaceing with
your machines, it was no longer
embodied work
usually doing by a white male --
now you have a drum
machine -- in South Africa is
one of the first music
to which you can now purely
dance. And the music
also generates -- and sort of
feedback loop between
continents produceed it, it's
the house music that
slowed down this time and slow
down music that is
ricocheting with American
elements and then being re
reAfricannizeed in other spaces.
Early disco, although
disco was although
attacked as plastic music for
plastic people, one of
the correct isms that was made
-- early disco did
not use synthesizeers or drum
machines, but in the
early years, it wasn't a feature
they used.
Question for bill is
how is the disco era
and disco culture, in how its
portrayed in moving
images -- has there been
how studio 54 portrayed --
where the pure disco CD's from
the 90's.
I haven't seen the
movie 54, but there's a
TV show called the get down,
which is a disco based
show, and I watched about two or
three episodes and
I couldn't watch it anymore. It
was so packaged for
commercial TV.
And it's
had some of the limits of the
disco that I remember, but it
was
that particular
time was so unique, and like I
said, before there
was so many factors that
contributeed to that perfect
storm, that you cancer really --
you can't do that
again, for example -- you
couldn't create a disco
again, because it's a different
time.
And the issues and people are
different. I
haven't seen anything currently
that really really
captures the essence of what I I
saw during that
period.
One question for all
of you which is going
to be very
pragmatic for the library of
Congress --
what are the roles of archives
and museums in terms
of provideing access that could
happen about an era
or a musical movement such as
disco and is there
significance that the library of
Congress promoting
disco, does that do something
for the study of disco
or is more important that local
public libraryies are
doing something related to it --
I would like to
open the floor on that kind of
topic.
I would love to have
it happening at all
levels, I think it's wonderful
that the library of
Congress has put this event on,
I think it's tear if
I can. But I know in my own
research what was really
important to me was going to
England actually, and
using some libraryies in England
where I was able to
look at the mucus press, because
the music press in
Britain actually was much more
systemic to this new
sound than to say reallying
stone or some of the
American music press so, in my
own research it was
really importance.
I mean, it's
fascinating -- I don't do a
lot of archival work in disco
but from the project
that I alludeed to today in my
presentation, I'm look
at the global
biography of music and sounds
from
Africa and taking up dance music
forms in the West
and classical music forms that's
broadly speaking
where my project is to find out
how this actually
happens historically, I have
been dependent on
libraryies mainly in Europe but
also here, that
indicated what kind of contact
was there, what was
ethical transcriptions, what
letters were written
through a exposeer and say an
African -- and the
movement of tape and cassette
and vinyl and
computers, all this media that
carryies imprints of
what might have happened.
Reconstructing history
is a no means feet
-- it is assumeed by some of us
that have liveed
through certain period, it needs
to leave traces and
documents, and I think library
ies are essential, even
if they don't seem very
populated spaces it takes
the research to bring it back,
libraryies have been
essential.
The only thing I can
comment on that is
there was an article in German
rolling stone in
November, and I had it translate
ed by my German
friend and they used pictures
from my book to
illustrate it, and writer
described how back in the
early Nazi days, there was kind
of what was the
disco of today in a sense that
the youth who are
maybe politically apathetical,
or apolitical, they
would meet under ground and they
would dance, and it
was kind of a rebellion sort of
thing but they would
do that and then talk a little
bit about what we're
going to do and the politics and
the things that
were going on. But it was really
like a celebration
of just being not part of what
was happening in the
world -- it was like a private
event.
So, he was trying to
sort of trace back
what happened in New York, to
that early
1939 era.
I would say also, just
to add this, I mean
mean, since the early adopters
of disco music were
marginalizeed groups, it's
especially important that
we have documentation, and it
makes specially
difficult too.
How would you document
your DJ sets if you
were to do it all over again?
That would be easy
actually -- yeah. It's
not difficult.
>> You use sound cloud
--
>> I don't myself --
believe me, I hardly
have the time. But I have some
of of those set
that's are written down, and I
had beats per minutes
chart, and so -- I didn't do
this for a very long
time, it was only for a few
years, so I have a
pretty good sense of what I
would segway, and I
practiced a lot, I was not a
natural born mixer, so
making that segway from one song
to next which was
so critical you had to do it
seamlessly -- I would
practice a lot and make tape for
friends and I have
some of those tapes.
With your photography
how do you archive
it or do you -- you have to do
that or else you're
not going to be disseminateing
-- are you thinking it
in the archival sense of where
it's going to go or
just a working kind of archive?
It's a body of work
that's now complete,
obviously, and the book that was
produceed -- the
photographers, is volume of that
work.
And it was trying to
cover as much as we
could in a short space.
I have
4 or 500 rows of film, and two
or
three other volume that's could
be produceed from
there and they would have
different feelings to them
them, different covering
different subject matter.
But, it's all just on
my computer at this
point. And I do get requests
from different people
for different purposes, articles
and -- do you have
a picture of the club, that kind
of thing.
So, it's ji sitting
there at this point.
Cool. Just add
something -- since we're
talking about documentation and
archives and so on
and the challenge that the
archive presents and non-
non-archive. Just to amplify
your point in relation
to some of the work that I'm
doing, is not just
marginalizeed communeityies but
in geographically
remote spaces, music tradition
that's don't have a
record or a history of
documentation by notation or
other modes of transmission --
sometimes more
effective than notation -- it's
not saying it's
better it's just a different
document that survives
a few more days of time. That
challenges another
layer of particularly if you're
trying to access
deep history.
With some of the stuff
I was tracing, if
you look at the Wikipedia page
or the mainstream
media or the big media -- the
way in which the
stories of these big songs is
full of information,
so we've experienced ourselves
as being information
edge, cornucopia all over and
there's primitive part
of redundancy, memory 15 years
or so -- on the
Beyonce page you may not be able
to find for that
sock -- you won't be able to
find that many
references that go beyond their
major label, you
have to do additional work and
you can't enter it on
the Wikipedia page because it
will throw you off --
it's got its rules. And you
can't get all the way to
Africa because at this point
most of that
information is just not known
even by the people
producing the music so you have
a really deep
challenge.
The other day I was
talking in the
institution about some of this
in relation of the
mathics practices in southern
Africa, which was wipe
wiped out as it happened.
You would after the lesson
wipe off the record -- the rest
we have copyright --
emerging at the time -- so
different rules of the
game mean that's the challenges
rough of the archive
are real and as we move into a
global era where the
copyright regime is in some
sense the dominant one
we need to do serious
constructive work. We depend
on the archives.
The library of
Congress is the home of the
U.S. copyright office and so
many of our music holds
is where we have the copyright
deposit of I will
survive or other things like
that and going back to
the late 1870's -- in your
unique professional world
world, in relation to each other
, what is the
important role of copyright and
how does it differ
based on the medium that's
you're seeking -- Alice
if you're sampling it -- sample
ing as a DJ, how
cognizant are you of the
copyright situation O bill,
when you're managing your
collection of photographs,
are you very flexible with their
use, or something
that you stick close to and then
for Martin do you
maybe place barriers with
copyright for your own
scholarship -- you don't have to
answer those and
just jump on copyright wherever.
Copyright is really
important for
photography and even copyright,
it doesn't protect
people from using my images,
especially with the
Internet, that's the big problem
for me. All the
image that's I have in this body
of work for disco
are copyrighted through the
library of Congress, but
I have the software program that
shows me in the
world is using images and it's
astonishing, all over
the world, announceing some club
opening will be one
of my pictures -- so, there's
not much that I can do
about it.
The way I see it, if
it's being used for a
real commercial money making
usage, then I can
actually go after them and let
them know, take it
down or pay me something.
But, copyrighting, I
know there's been
some changes in terms of traffic
copyrighting lately
lately, and I'm not really up on
it, but I know it's
become much more difficult and
harder for
photographers and I would like
to see that easeed
down.
Well, copyright, I
mean, it's been decades
since I was teaching, so, I mean
, I guess
I had
problems when I was writing
books getting the
ability it quote lyrics and
obviously you know in
today's world you cannot quote
very much, and that's
kind of a drag.
On the other hand, you
know somebody who
writes, it pains me when I go
online and I see
somebody has downloaded my whole
book, whether it's
the Janice book or the disco
book or any other book,
can we do something about this,
maybe for a week but
it will come back up. So
copyright --
I'm going to switch
the question a little
bit to the content of some of
the work rather than
the problems I have encountered
which are similar to
both of you and I think it's the
central issue of
our time. We have a kind of
micro economy which is
deeply fueled by new technology
ies in music
exacerbated by the MP3 effect by
Napster, which
means the geneie of the form
came out of the bottle
and became free and a period of
time were the
commodity debates rational sound
are free and the
concept that's have become
expensive. So, a huge
increase in prices in music
concert watching --
Because that's how
artists can make their
money now.
>> That's right. The
way -- in this pre
precopyright age where you have
to become the
contributor -- this is the
fascinating problem -- I
would take the work that I
presented is a number of
serious copyright issue that's
emerge, and in many
artists being used along the way
, it's a corporate
endeavor which is practice in
the industry, the
authors are not the one that's
are necessarily
properly money advertise inside
that arrangement.
You have Peter Hugo as a
photographer, he makes an
appearance in his work --
people are less aware of
queer transfigure from New
Orleans, doing some
social work by drawing attention
to these intense
beautiful and powerful sub
cultures but at the same
time, the sample of the voice is
left unmon
advertiseed. So you have this
difference but the
political economy under cuts
against the grain of
the deeper message of those
songs.
So in the song I
presented was paid
-- it
didn't start there -- that's why
I was giving you
the layers, the irony, everybody
that was not the
artist got a piece of the pie
but the through artist
at the source, there's always a
source behind the
source but we can push it a
little further -- the
respect for the proper demands
of the author concept
is very often in a crisis today,
and we feel it.
The copyright office
has put together a
really fun thing which is a
westbound page dedicated
to exploreing copyright through
disco, and it's
copyright.gov/disco, you can
explore the catalog to
see what types of registration
came in, you will see
that gloria Gaynor did not write
I will survive.
Tonight you can get a
fun introduction of
copyright, you get a present out
of your photo and
the basics of copyright process
and how important it
is to creators.
Make us all more aware
of that process.
So before we open it
up to Q&A -- I would
like to ask one more question --
where do you see
disco's reception in ten years
compareed to where we
are now?
I think, certainly one of the
things that
I found fascinating of what's
happened -- we started
talking about the cultural
memory around disco, and
I think certainly, one of the
things that I was
struck bias I was writing my
book is the extent
disco had been treated as a kind
of joke in its time
had become for both queer
artists and artists who in
some respects allyies, everybody
from the pet shop
boys to lady gaga and beyond,
that disco had become
understood not as a kind of
regressive political and
musical move but rather as trans
guesssive because of
the dissociations with gay
liberation, and this real
break with the past of
repression.
I think it's very hard
to know what the
future is.
And how disco is going
to be understood
ten years down the line, but I
do think that
probably this vilification and
demonization of disco
is probably behind us.
Great.
I think that -- I
don't think that the
perception of disco from that
era is ever going to
really change. I think it is
what it is. But I think
the music itself has evolveed
certainly -- after New
York it went to Chicago and
became house music, and
went to Detroit, it's EDM and I
can what happened in
my case was in early 2000 this
record producer who
produces what's contemporary ED
DM umusic, all of a
sudden these younger people
realize this comes from
disco, so I think that there's a
new respect for
disco in a sense, as being the
source of a lot of
the new music that's out there
today. And, yeah, I
think that's changed a little
bit of the
feeling of
the kind of sillyiness of what
we think of as disco
back then. But I think it's
evolveed. Martin do you
have any thoughts?
Beside of occurring
kind of retro--
speak
busy music history as becoming
retrothat looks back
and picks up pieces and he's not
excited about that,
he thinks it's eating on the
seats of culture.
But I think I would
take the line that has
been suggested by both of the
previous speakers in
the following sense, in some
sense disco kind of
went out in the way to these
multiply multiplypel dance forms
-- if we look at the shifting of
time, the that
thattening of harmonic space is
such that anicut the
functional principal of cords
moving in traditional
ways, think Donna summer, the
extended space, the
fact of what was once a high hat
in the off beat
that became a dominant sound of
mainstream dance
music as well as IDM and IDM --
in terms of the
grammar beactually find that's a
perspective toll
moment that in one sense could
argue generateed an
after life which is much bigger,
and the question of
the focal point of a historical
emanating moment, I
think is hard to contest.
I think it really did
shift pop music,
musical architecture in very
important ways, and I
suspect it's going to continue
to have an influence
-- there's nothing to indicate
this is changing any
time soon.
Fascinating -- the
time is here for you to
ask the experts, so to speak --
there are microphone
microphones at the front of the
aisle on either side
side, if you wouldn't mind
walking up to the
microphones and sharing your
question, and as soon
as you have asked your question
you're free to
return to your seat.
I have a question for
bill -- I first saw
the body of work you were
sharing at a different
institution, New York museum of
sex where it had
been installed in a separate
room with a bar and
everything, can you talk about
how that show you
came about and what the purpose
of that was or --
>> Yeah, sure. There's
I guess about a
year ago I got a call -- I live
in New York, from
the curator of the museum of sex
on 5th avenue and
27th street, and they were
looking for something
to cover the disco era, and they
came across my book
book. The thing they looked boo
my book was the fact
that they didn't want to focus
on celebrityies celebrityies,
they
wanted to focus more on the
culture of disco. So
they asked if they could use one
of my pictures as a
subway add, and there was some
discussion at some
point turning this into a
exhibition. They ran the
add and we had later discussions
and talked about
what we would do. And my general
idea was that it
would be great if you could
create a space which
they had actually, where you
could walk in off the
street in 2017 back to 1997 and
be in the -- have a
feeling of a disco in that time,
and so that was
kind of where the starting point
of it all.
So they did a terrific
job creating the
lighting and rework the the
entire room. There is a
bar there and they do serve
drink from that era like
Long Island iced tea and at 1970
's prices too -- and
the exhibits were free too --
it's a good excuse to
go to the museum of sex. Most
people don't want to
go -- it's free, and they picked
out a selection of
my images that really describe
about six or seven
different clubs, and they also
added some picture
that's aren't in the book
because of the sexual
nature of them, because I wanted
to describe that
part of it because it's a museum
of sex.
And the literature
really describes each
one of the clubs and how it
started and who started
it and who went there --
and it's become very
popular -- it was supposed to go
up until February
and then they extended it
million the end of the
year. If anyone is in New York
it's really a fun
thing to do.
Sir?
Hello. Thank you for
being here. My
question obviously disco is
importance and that's
why we're here. I feel like one
of the main theme
that's coming out of this is
that disco created this
inclusion andem appointment and
that's what made it
important, but then it lends
itself to modification
-- this is more of an open ended
question but I
think it's one of the things
behind backlash against
disco, and I wondered if the pan
el has thoughts on
inclusion empowerment and easy
demodification.
I think you were asked
about
the reasons of disco
sort of the whipping boy, right?
I think it's
interesting because I think it's
true certainly
people that were in the gay
movement political
movement, assumed that it would
be communeity centers
centers, gay communeity centers
and gay communeity
dances held in those centers and
the activities out
of the centers that would become
the glue for gay
men and their communeityies. And
I said in fact it
turned out to be the bathhouses
and the discos.
Dennis atman one of the gay
activists said he found
it ironic and disappointing that
as gay men, I think
also lesbians became freeer,
they also became more
reliant on business institutions
.
I think that's true.
On the other hand,
you have another bay writer,
this person from
Britain, a cultural study
scholar, as early as 1979
was making the argument that in
some of
circumstances capital cultural
production, disco can
produce an even transGreg result
. So scholars debate
commodification and have been
doing it for decades.
They've been doing it since the
1920's. It turns out
it would suggest there was a lot
wrong in the 1920's
unincluding the income and
equality -- and because
we've exceeded it but it's true
for people of color
and women, people who in some
respects wereen the
margin culturally,
commodification whether it was
happening in the movies or the
spread of movies or
the persuade of department
stores could have -- this
may seem counter intuitive but
could be useed in ways
to be understood to be
liberatory to those groups. A
lot of scholar September really
debating this. Ad
good question.
Also, I think I want
to make two sort of
additional points about that,
one is I'm not sure
that all forms of
commodification are at some low
with some social project, when
it comes to -- I'm
speculating a little bit, but
these gay liberations,
it's deeply
in social and cultural icons
and symbols symbols
that are on television and
online, modern family and
stuff, that played a role, it
wasn't just on the
pickle fence, picketingalgory,
it was happening in a
I think the history
of music, the role of automay
have technologyies has
put people out of work. We have
-- music is the van
guard of this. So back to the TR
-- in the context
of house music became the way to
get up the party,
and became surfacessha are like
yours, where people
if I form and headed
to the technologyies where we're
going to put people
out of work. I think it's a
tricky question, --
I would also add that
one of the reasons
that so many rock and rollers he
sented disco of
course is that very many of
their clubs and bars
were turned into discos and they
had no work.
And that was a real
complaint. And an
understandable grievance.
I'm up here in the
back -- way up in the
back because I can't get down to
the microphones
down there -- my question is for
Alice, and I wanted
to ask about the phenomena of
grace Jones and the
gay communeity during the disco
era and if you have
any commence busy that
particularly in reference to
the paradise garage which was a
big meeting place
during the disco era that grace
gone Jones was
practically royalty.
Grace Jones a very
important figure, she
turned up at studio 54 too --
but the garage was
important discos in New
York City and it was important
because it resisted
quite deliberately that
kind of exconclusionism that
was in some discos. Again, the
people who -- medical
was one of the those people that
I had in my talk
were quite deliberate in trying
to make a space that
really truly was inclusive and I
think grace Jones
was a really importance figure
because whatever her
own sexual desires, wherever
they went, I don't know
anything about, but she was
certainly somebody who
in the way that she presented as
queer, and so, she
-- she could be understood, she
could be understood
as arch ally, so I think she was
a very important
figure, again, as I think the
women of label were as
well.
I wanted to make a.
comment and add on to
the stuff you were talking about
-- one of them is
that the disco era that music
has been recycleed over
and over again, and one of the
other things is the
musicians of that time they're
still out there and
touring, we need to make sure we
don't forget, the
gloria Gaynors, the bee jees
were doing some stuff
before, some of the brothers
started doing and some
of the musicians of that time
are still touring,
that music is still alive -- the
DJ's and young rap
rappers and musicians of today
are sampling
tremendously of that era. So
comment on what you're
saying where is the music going
to -- I don't think
it's going to ever die, someone
's always going to do
a 70's theme party, that's going
on, it's an easy go
to, if you wanted to do to theme
party -- it's
always going to be around but
maybe change in some
instances but it's all going to
be the core, 70's
music that core disco is always
going to be there
and what it's going to be in the
future?
In terms of rap, so
much of the rhythmic
architecture of early rap was
the sample used in the
first big crossover rap record.
By grand master flash
or by the sugar hill
gang -- I stand corrected.
It's absolutely true
and inscapeable.
Yes, exactly. Exactly.
My question is having
liveed through all of
that music and it's about the
beat, it distinguishes
it and it's great for me to come
to this, for me it
was all merging into one.  I was
going one time hear
hearingth wind and fire, the
next thing
-- the
distinguish between the disco
until I came here, I
knew who I liked, I would see
knowna Hendricks and
all of them, but I didn't see
that clear distinction
-- so that's why I agree with
her too I don't think
it will ever go away, I just
think it kind of evolve
evolves as you said. But what
you mentioned a little
bit -- but is it the base -- I
hear the base in
everything -- but that's me.
So, what would you say
is specifically the
beat in disco that distinguishes
it from fung Dellic
Dellics or anybody else?
That's a great
question. What really is
disco.
I think the
fun was pretty important and
that was deriveed from mow town.
I hear -- I see the
different singers but
I'm trying --
I think there are some
distinctions and
this derive from the music
coming from Philadelphia
-- and they were creating soul
music that was silky
silkier, there were different
instruments being used
-- instead of the tropical bone
they would use the
hop, they would use different
sounds and and they
were going for a more deliberate
ly sophisticated
sound. That's why I was saying
in some sense you can
understand what they were doing
as an active of
rebellion against the nothing
that soul music had to
sound a particular way. One of
my favorite quotes is
from marry Wilson from the
supremes, I was confamily
-- the supremes were always
being criticized noting
being soulful enough -- why is
it that I have to
sound like Aretha Franklin --
why can't there be
diverseity.
I think disco did
amplify mow town music
in the sense that month town was
deliberately
working to try to get out of
what had once been
called the -- felt by white
Americans but not in a
way that in my view that
compromised that music.
That music was soulful.
Mow town was soulful
and disco music was
soulful. But I think it's very,
very difficult -- to
try to actually what was disco,
what is disco -- one
of the things that I argue in
hot stuff is it's
curious to me the extent to
which we try to create
very narrow sort of categories
for disco and what
constitutes it for disco and
it's not true for rock
music. You say pupping rock is
considered rock music
music, you can say blues rock,
country rock, it's
considered rock, no one is try
ing to coordinate it
off and put it in its own box.
For disco, it's
assumed that David Bowie
sustained wasn't disco, but
at the time it was heard and
discussed as disco.
What about PI oh -- which played
at studio 54 --
that was disco.
Blondey was disco,
Madonna was disco. Lord
Lords of green light sound disco
to me. I take the
action pansive view.
To the question of the
beat --
there's one
thing I would want to pull out
and draw attention to
is how the beat is organized.
And I think there's
prominence again to open high
hat between the
documents beat so when you tune
boo a song that
doesn't have many cord changes
it takes on hip not
nottic character -- it almost --
you can't quite
tell if it's speeding up or slow
ing down,
accelerating effect within that
environment. And
that begins a dominant feature
of how the beat gets
organized and then that gets
pulled into a prominent
way, almost a -- one might want
to make a
speculative case how that relate
s to subculturals.
We think of Shaka Kahn, 1974,
tell me something good
good, that's taking fung to a
new level and the in
between beat, so we have these
moment that's give us
syntax for disco.
Written by Stevie
Wonder wasn't it?
I'm not sure? I think
so. The interesting
thing about
Shaka Kahn's group, they did
not
-- they
developed some strange names for
what they did but
saw themselves at the
intersection of fung and rock,
as did label.
Time for one last
question.
I wanted to make a
comment -- when
dop
became rock and roll, it was the
advent of the
guitar, and you would clearly
say when Bob Dylan
went electric, that was a huge
movement. Did
anything in disco reach that?
Bow didly has his own
beat, and I don't think it was
the heartist who are
trying to define themselves, it
was the radio
stations -- radio stations
decided what they were
going to play, and as disco was
in its hey day, the
eagles were still being played
on other radio
stations, selling trillions of
records, so it's the
market place, and it's where you
get broadcast in
the marketplace, so someone DJ
might say,
-- I'm
sorry to play I don't want to
play PIL -- where
where we can download and stream
and do whatever we
want to do but until that happen
ed people were
prisons of a certain radio
station and what was
there and what they were paying.
>> I'm going to take
issue with you at
this.  Because here's the thing
-- people were
always saying about disco, it
was something that was
basically cooked up in the back
room by these major
label guys.
>> No, I worked at
Atlantic records, I was
director of publicity of all of
that, and it was
money -- people were in the it
for the money. What's
hot, what's new --
But people, the idea
that music -- the
outside of the commercial is a
dilution, I think.
But let's talk about the very
early days of the
music of disco. The first big
disco hit was
Barry
white's love unlimited orchestra
-- 1973 -- radio
did not break that song. In fact
, his label was
completely uninterested in
promoteing that song. What
happened was two very enterprise
ing DJ's were
visiting somebody at Barry white
's label and there
was a dead album box, they had
these bins of dead Al
bums -- and these DJ's find
Barry white's album
there, and they played it in the
clubs and it was
the first time that a single had
been broken in the
clubs and then it went to --
>> I would be very
careful saying first
time -- you claim something
being a first disco
record, they've been arguing for
50 years what's the
first rock and roll record.
>> I'm saying it's the
first disco record
to become a huge hit --
>>
I would have to see
the documentation --
>>
You can buy her book.
I wanted another
point.
We don't have time --
disco is an
important topic that deserves
scholarly attention.
So this is a whole body of work
just craving to be
unearthed and these are some of
the pioneers in
distinct that work. If you're a
grad student or
undergrad even and you want to
do a cool paper, come
to library Congress, who was
making money off of
them, versus people doing the
creative work, who is
ripping off the to thes, how is
bill protecting his
photos. There's so much study in
this area of study,
and kind of me, the way that
popular musical genres
are becoming more of the hot
thing in scholarship.
There's only so much that we can
do -- well no, I'm
not going to say that because
I'll get in trouble --
there's a of other music genres
that need that
attention, that discourse that
we find out what was
really going on -- I grew up
with disco, I heard it
from my parents listening to
their records and then
I got my
subscription -- and I have one
and two --
and then you get a certain
perception of what you
grow up and what's in the media
-- it's not
necessarily of all that was
going on and bill's book
sheds light on that which is
fantastic. And if you
want to go back and see the film
54, you can compare
that to what the actual primary
source document
revealed. There's a lot of fun
stuff to do -- if
you're not a researcher, just
come and hang out and
he can
explore because that's what
we're here for all
people, regard will of your
interest, academic, high
school student, if you're home
patrolling Twitter
you'll find interesting stuff at
library of Congress
Congress.
We have a giant
surprise for you -- so you
need to stay in your seats.
Before with you get to
the surprise,
logistics for the book signing
you're going to exit
up the top, you'll be directed
to purchase books or
go right into the book signing
room. There will be a
limit of one item per person per
author. If you do
not have tickets for the Gloria
Gaynor live event
this evening, there will be a
line outside beginning
at 5:30. It might be a good idea
to have din are and
come back later -- not all of
your colleagues are
committed to their tickets, and
there's a very goods
chaps you will get in tonight if
you don't have a
ticket.
So while we change
over the set briefly,
feel free to tweet. Hashtag L LT
disco -- find
outweighs you can support our
programming or
copyright.gov/disco -- thank you
Martin, Alice and
bill.
(APPLAUSE).
Welcome everyone to
library of Congress --
my name is Nicholas brown -- the
library of Congress
is the largest library of the
world and we have the
largest music library in the
world. We're doing it
all day today, can we give it up
for the viewers
that are all over the words?
(APPLAUSE).
This is a month long look at
disco music,
dance, fashion and culture,
where it came from and
how influence popular cultures
sin the 1970's.
These programs are been made
through partnership
through a host of organizations
based here in D A
and nationally recognizeed,
capital, pride, the
district of Columbia, and the
silent dance society.
This program
specifically is made possible
at the library of Congress
through private donations
donations. If you would like to
see more programs
like this we invite you to
visit LC -- disco to make
an amount of your choosing. The
events we invite you
to live tweet, and tag at
library of Congress and@LI
and@LIBN of Congress which is
Dr. Hayden's Twitter
account.
Now if you thought
bib low discoesque was
awesome we have other things --
a new pop up series
beginning in June called pride
in the library,
featureing LGBT items items and
then the following week
also in June we're opening
library of awesome which
is the title, and it is
happening at the same time
as awesome con, bringing out the
unparallel
comeic
books -- you can visiting our
website to find out
all of the details. We're going
to do the outdoor
summer series, --
Now without further a
do you I'm going to
bring out a very special treat
for you. Here at the
library of Congress we're
fortunate to have a great
task of librarians and subject
technicians and
capitol police, and something
that brings us all
together is amazing leadership,
we have some of the
hippest librarians librarians
that are found anywhere in the
world. And the two hippest ones
for you are going to
be Dr. Carla Hayden, who is the
14th libraryian of
Congress and Robert Lou then --
please given it up
for them.
(APPLAUSE)
.
(MUSIC)
Okay, here's the pitful part,
we've been
practicing that for weeks.
We really have.
Welcome everybody to
disco -- at the
library
of Congress, thank you Nicholas
brown for
all your hard work.
(APPLAUSE).
Thank you for all the work
you've do not
to make this possible.
So, Dr. Hayden, we're products
of the 70's
70's, we started out at as
librarians in the 70's
and still here.
We went to library
school in the 70's and
made this through and Robert
started a career at
library of Congress and I went
to teach and public
libraryies and here we are 40
something years later
together as partners, so we're
thankful.
(APPLAUSE).
Now, we also were
talking about 70's
fashion, you'll notice what
we're wearing.
This is as far as we
can go now.
Wait until
tonight, does she have an
outfit --
Let's just say there's
going to be more
hair. I couldn't grow it back
then, by the time I
grew it the 70's were over.
What we're seeing is
the fashion in the 70
70's when we looked back at some
of the photos and
we said oh my God, it's an
oxymoron, fashion and the
70's, however, you could excuse
the fashion because
of the music --
It's true. And tell me
what was your
favorite disco song of the era?
The one that still
stays with me and
that's why they were playing
while we came out, we
are family. It symbolizes so
much in term there's
all kinds of family and it
brings everybody together
together, so I was really
pleased to select it this
year to be put into the national
registry.
(APPLAUSE).
Now, you should know before I
got here
Robert was part of the selection
process, and he got
to select your favorite disco
song.
Three
guesses -- I will survive.
(APPLAUSE).
One of the exciteing things that
we can
place wonderful song that's have
a great legacy like
this on the national recording
registry, and it's
something that you can
contribute to as well. All
you have to do is go to to our
website LSD.gov and
search recording registry and
make suggestions to
what you would like to see on
that registry.
Think about it because
it's not just song
that's maybe were the top 20,
there's song that's
resonate with you and we want to
also use the
registry to introduce people to
music and
significant works of art, and
just culture, so think
of any song or any recording
that you would like us
to consider. And we would love
to have it.
Think about today as
being a window as
into the entire selection of
music in the library of
Congress and it's an amazing
collection and I hope
you take the opportunity to
explore it.
So speaking of the I
will survive, the
reason we're really here today
is because of the
music and the persona really of
the legend dare
Gloria Gaynor.
(APPLAUSE).
You warns to talk
about us all -- I feel
like we're at the academy awards
.
I do -- her him song I
will survive was
recorded into the national
registry in 2016 --
letterle general dare career
spans pri years.
Looks better.
And has never lost
sometime. We have the
privilege of being backstage and
we were showing her
some treasures from our
collection, the original
manuscript -- and she started
seeing summertime --
and was quite a moment.
And she then looked at
the score, and this
is in George garnish
-- hand, one of my favorite
songs, our love is here to stay,
and then she
started to hum that. Robert had
a moment.
Yeah.
I was -- it was really
wonderful. And one
of the things that she will be
talking about today
is her second book we will
survive, true stories of
encouragement, inspiration and
the power of song.
And joining her on
stage to discuss her
book and her career is a person
you invite to your
home every morning -- I know my
mother does, and
there are very few things that
you can do to
sometimes either impression your
parents or to show
them their efforts were worth it
, I was able to let
her stand by and meet the co
anchor of ABC's good
morning America the Mrs. Robin
Roberts.
(APPLAUSE).
So, without furtherra do you,
please
welcome to the library of
Congress, Robin Roberts
and the one and only Gloria
Gaynor.
(APPLAUSE).
We love you, they love you.
Thank you.
I'm a child of the 70
's honey, proud of it
it.
Loveing it. Gloria
Gaynor. I'm telling you,
you have just inspireed me and
countless others and
I've been looking forward to
sitting and chatting
with you and getting people to
know more of you --
you grew up with music -- tell
us about it.
My mother sang,
my father sang as well but
my father did sing professional
ly for a time, as a
matter of fact, he was the
opening act for an act
back then called stepping --
What was that again?
Stepping -- and
it was just in the
neighborhood -- they would sing
and on the street
corners and in front of the
house and wherever they
could -- when I was growing up
-- where I grew up,
these bands would collect on the
street corns during
the summer and start playing
Congo go drums appears
singing and dancing and as I
grew up as a teenageer
going to high school I was very
sad inned that the
everywhere.
Isn't that sad what
you grew up with you
feel that's the world.
That's the world.
Yeah,ing exactly. When
did you realize
that disco was going to be its
own genre?
I realizeed that when
I was still singing
rhythm and blues and jazz. I was
performing up and
down the East coast and a lot in
New York City and
in cab cab rays -- the disco
music started coming out
and Barry white
-- Barry white I was called the
King
of disco -- they were in the
club, in the cab ray
clubs that I was working in they
started to move
chairs and make dance floors and
have -- there would
be a closet, they would open the
door, cut the top
after half of it off, put a
Planck across the bottom
half of it and that was where
the can DJ turn table
set was set and there was your
disco tech.
Just like that.
Just like that. And
somebody got the idea
to build disco techs, build
establishments that were
specifically for who wanted to
come in and dance.
This is when I realizeed this is
going to happen.
This is a market that doesn't
have any music at the
moment, has
-- I think I'm going to supply
them.
Yes you did. You most
certainly did and
we're glad you did.
Fulfill a need.
How did you go about
-- I will Sue,
creating that, writing that?
I didn't write it at
all.
I was in performing in
New York and fell
backwards over a monitor during
a performance, jump
jumped back up, finished my show
, went back home,
woke up the next morning being
from the waste down
-- but only paralyzeed for that
period of time and
then a while after I got to
hospital, whatever they
did they relieved the work and
the paralysis was
gone -- I don't remember
anything but saying did
they serve lunch yet?
Priorities.
From March until July
because they were
trying everything they could,
traction and spinal
tap, it was scary -- there was
no such thing as an M
MRI, so they were trying to find
out what was going
wrong and what they could do so
they gave me surgery
on my spine and had a fusion,
bon graph from my hips
and all of that.
So when I was in the
hospital, I was like
what do you mean by about this?
What are we going to
do -- the record company said
they were not going to
renew my contract, people going
around saying the
queen is dead -- I was praying
-- I hasn't parade
for a long time -- so I was like
praying -- I got a
Bible and started reading and I
all right the
hospital quite confident that
God was going to do
something but I didn't know what
.
While I was at home, a
few weeks later the
record company said they were
not going to end my
contact and they want medicine
to go to California
and record a song that the
record company President
had chosen. I wanted to know
what --
You remember B slide
--
Yes, if you didn't
clap, Salus ask the
person next to you.
The B side was called substitute
substitute, I said what is going
to be the A side --
I said what is going to be the B
side, they said
well, what kind of songs do you
like -- I said I
like songs that are meaningful
that touch people's
hearts, have good melodyies,
people can sing along --
we said -- we recorded this song
two years ago, they
hell I will survive for two
years waiting for the
right person.
And you were the right
person.
Yes. And I just looked
up and said thank
you.
Because when I read
the lyrics I realizeed
this was a timeless lyric, I
said this is a human
humanless lyric, are you stupid
-- you were going to
put this on the B side -- I said
if it's got
anything to do with me it will
get a chance now.
It's a timeless lyric.
You knew it.
I knew it when I read
the lyrics -- I'm
relateing to this song -- this
happened like nine
years since my mother passed
away, it was something
I thought I never would survive
-- I was still
suffering from that -- those of
you that lost your
parent, you're still suffering.
So, yeah, I thought
anybody -- everybody
is going to be able to relate to
this and type has
approve me right.
So when you stepped on
the statement and
sang that what was the response
from the audience,
how it did it resonate with
people.
When I got the song in
my hands and took
it to the record company to say
this should be the A
side, they wouldn't listen to it
. The President had
chosen another song and nobody
wanted to go against
his choices. So we went to
studio a 54, gave it to
the DJ there and the audience
immediately loveed it.
I said I know I'm right. New
York audiences are soja
ided, they don't immediately
love anything. So this
is right.
We gave minimum a
stack of them, he gave
them to his friends around New
York and they began
to play it, people began to
request it on radio,
they want it on the way home, on
the way to work and
the rest is history.
1970's this music is bringing
people from
diverse communeityies together,
they have a voice,
what was that experience like?
It was a discovery for
me -- I discovered
that there was one music, the
only music in the
history of music, ever to bring
together people onto
the dance floor, from every
inability, creed, color
and age group, and that was
amazing to me and I was
in the forefront of that, so I
felt really prismed,
really great about it,
especially since it's so
uplifting and encourageing --
you didn't bring people
to money together -- you didn't
bring people to
complain, you brought people
together to uplift and
encourage and inspire one
another. And this is why
I've done a website called I
will survive dot.org,
please go to because it's a
communeity for that very
purpose, where people come
together and tell theory
stories, uplift and encourage
one another, it's a
charity based website on which
you can purchase, we
love to purchase, and at the
same time support a
charity of your choice and some
of the chaiityies are
represented -- I don't know --
they're going to be
here --
(APPLAUSE).
There's
BCRS -- there's thrive --
there's
taps for the veterans
-- please go on and see all of
these charity that
you can support while you're
encourageing and uplift
uplifting one another.
When you say I will
survive everyone can
take it personally and use it
differently -- it
means something different for
everyone doesn't it.
Yes, it does. It
request be applied to so
many different areas of your
life. So many different
things. all of which, any of
which might be things
that you are
feeling and hoping you'll
survive. And
that way we can relate to one
another because of
those things.
I can relate when you
were talking about
-- my mom and dad are cheering
us right now from our
Heavenly balance conny, how am I
going to survive
without them and health crisis,
and I understand, so
many people, who are fellow
thriveers that have
surviveed, it's been your and
them, and to know --
library of Congress, and we
heard earlier --
(APPLAUSE).
Come on now. Come on.
What's -- what that
means -- what's that mean?
My friends it's not
normal for me to be
speechless -- but it does --
it's overwhelming -- to
know that someone who started
from such humble begin
beginnings that I can say that
I'm now going to be
history. People will come for
years to come and be
inspireed by something that I've
done -- something
that I've been a part of. And
it's such an honor.
It's such an unbelieveable honor
. To be here, to be
sitting before you, to be a part
of the library of
Congress, to be inducted into
the library of
Congress, to be a part of
American history, it is
wonderful, and it's not only
wonderful because for
me, but I'm hoping that
it's wonderful for people
who started like me, and are
starting out even now
like me, to know what heights
you can reach, simply
by the gifts and talents that
God has placeed in you,
we all have them.
Yes, I love that.
(APPLAUSE).
You know, Gloria, as
you became emotional
as were looking at arts, years
from now there's
going to be somebody like
yourself coming in and
they're going to see your music
and see I will
survive, and that -- just talk
about how you became
emotional when seeing the great
recordings that are
here and the great archive
that's are here.
I looked at the music
and realizeed that I
was being -- having the
privilege of being
transported back in time -- we
don't need a time
machine -- to be transported
back in time to
experience and gain the rich the
benefit by the rich
legacy that other artists and
other people have left
from their arts, from their
talents and their
abilityies, this is what this
place is all about, and
what an honor to stand there and
see that, and be a
part of it and to
experience it and to know that
people can
benefit from these wonderful
things.
Can you express the
importance of it, for
not only you, the general public
that can come here
and witness this this and see it
, and also know that
disco, the culture, the fashion,
all of it -- it's
part of us and you brought this
here.
It's point for
self-discovery, it's
important photo recognize you
can do this. Anybody
can do this. Just
hone in on what you have and
what
you are and being recognizeed.
I said recently you
are designers of original.
Everyone single of us is
a designer of original. Every
similar one of us has
been given something to
contribute to the better. To
the welfare to the progress, to
the pleasure of
mankind.
And if we honeed in on
what that is, not
try to be someone else, not try
to
have -- recognize
what that is and be about
finding out what your
purpose is and bringing that
purpose to the part, so
to speak.
It's a wonderful thing
, because that's
what we're all meant to do, and
deep down inside
somewhere that's what each of us
wants to do.
We have great guardian
s here, the people,
the staff, the library of
Congress, don't we?
They are special
people. Had is what they
bring. This is their particular
talent, they're
particular ability to preserve
what we've done --
everything that is being
preserveed here is showing
off their talent, their ability
ies, their
desire to
be a part of human kind, to add
to, to contribute to
human kind.
Their passion and compassion.
Is parallel.
And now I will survive
will be one of them
them. I know you performed 30
anniversary Michael
Jackson concert -- thriller is
also here. Okay. The
album -- I know a little bit
about that -- this
brings me back -- to migrate
College days. What was
it like to perform for Michael
Jackson, and not very
many people got to know him.
It was wonderful to
perform for and I
believe to the constant survivor
-- he surviveed
things throughout his life and
have him sitting in
the audience and applauding and
smiling was
absolutely wonderful. I became
295-cent grade A ham
-- I had to do my best for the
best, and it was
wonderful.
Give us some back
stories for some other
things -- I am what I am.
I am what I am was
brought to me by my
producer, Eds been to the play
-- and heard the song
-- sitting in his seat watching
the play he thought
it would make a great disco song
, called me the next
day and had me listen to his
idea for the song. I
was like this is great idea and
I was very happy to
do that. And I was thinking of
-- I have going
through the lyrics, I was
thinking of all the
different things, all the
different reasons that
people need to say I am what I
am, as I said I'm a
designer's original, I'm not
anymore or any less
than you or anybody else, and
because of who I am
and how I look and what I wear
and how I think and
how I feel, any of that -- and
yeah --
>>
I am what I am.
Everyone wants to us --
your part of something and
that's why I am what I am
and other songs you have brought
to us, do you think
that's part of the message about
being inclusive?
Yes I really do
because I think that's why
disco music is so popular
because it is include,
like I said every
race, creed, color, come
together,
let's be a family, and if you
wouldn't mind -- if
you wouldn't mine I have
something that I think I
would like to say and it fits
right here -- I'm
going to walk over to the podium
and do this --
You.
(APPLAUSE).
Bear with me as I do
this.
Are these working?
Wonderful.
Survive is defineed as to remain
alive tox
sustain once self, pull through
on or out. In 1978 I
recorded the song -- since then
millions of men,
women and children have develop
ed this song as their
mantra including myself. Through
the years what we
were hoping in our hearts I'm
going to thrive,
thrive is defineed as continue
to live despite of
danger, hardship and keep going
through difficult
circumstances and we need to
recognize that and be
aware of other people's
structures and be willing to
help when and where we can. We
don't care about
others we can't expect anyone to
care about us. And
none of us will survive. It one
group starts to
perpetrate
a hateful act with others -- it
provides
others groups to do the same,
until acts become
common place and normal.
The death camps, the
slaveery, the South
Africa -- the slaveer of the
confederate states --
the Earth in this case cleaning,
all went on far too
long and those that managed to
survive did not do so
without the help and concern and
caring of others.
Any of it can happen again,
anywhere at any time.
The only thing necessary for
evil to prevail is for
good men to do nothing.
So it is up to each
one of us to read
about, know the stories, relate,
tell and discuss
the stories with others to keep
them fresh in our
minds because if we don't care
about all persons and
watch on the for each other evil
will prevail and no
one is except.
These United States of
America used to
stand for under the banner of
one nation under God
inDavissibility with liberty and
justice and all.
Part of liberty and justice
means what I believe to
be truth is different from what
you believe to be
truth. We can and do share what
we each believe
without reapproach from one
another. It means we are
able to disagree without being
disagreeable. We
share our beliefs without
condemnation. It means we
speak the truth to one another
and love. It means
that we respect one another N
enough to examine what
the other believes to be the
truth, define what the
truth we might be angle to
accept. It means that we
are sure what we believe what is
true we show no
hostility, disdain arrogance or
anger towards anyone
anyone's point of view. We show
no hostility, we
have no problem listening to
what somebody else has
to say because we're confident
in our own beliefs.
If I had a diamond and
somebody else had a
cubic sir Kona and thought it
was just as valuable
as my diamond I wouldn't be
angry with them. I would
fry to share with them what I
know to be the
difference and the benefit of a
diamond and what it
has -- the benefit it has, if
they refuse to listen,
I would hope and pray somebody
else and would one
day be able to explain so they
can receive it.
If that never happened
that person would
simply lose out when they would
get to retirement
age and I would be very sorry
for them but I would
have done all I could help. In
attitude in dealing
with others is the only way to
live in peace and
harmony with others with
different ideas and
ideologyies. Because the
popularity of I will survive
my name has become
-- of course getting on in age
--
I have to admit adds a little to
that.
Among the many things
that extensive
travel has done for me is it
convinced me of
something, that I live in the
greatest country in
the world.
I have off continue
said I am
295 and a
half% American, we sing God less
America, well what
I've seen and experienced in my
travels God has
blessed America. My travels have
made me cog glance
of the fact that we're the
babies or teenagers of
the world and are pretty much
running things.
America has become a teenage
rock sister.
I learn that people of
other nations have
loveed and respected us, they've
copyied everything
from our politics to our bad
habits and every
changing fashion sense -- and
our bad eating habits.
I called McDonald's our American
am ambassador
because it's everywhere.
I also find we have
the best japing food
in the world. Depending on your
point of view we're
the richest country in the world
. Why? We have
become like international rock
stars in every way.
We seem to be so wrapped up with
our fame and
fortunate that we have gun to
believe our own
height
-- smooth over the bad publicity
, like the teenager
teenage rock star.
It seems to me trying
to analyze any ills,
we down play the cause of any
problems and treat the
symptoms.
I'm not a political
person, but I say it's
a safe bet that a lot needs to
change.
One thing, we have
become a nation that's
upset with treating symptoms.
Identify said to my
friends we here in the America
got the recommend did
I for whatever -- if you have
pain we have the
process to get rid of the pain.
We have got to
become concerned with treating
the core and causes
of our problems. We got to get
back to absolute,
without absolute we will perish.
We know right from
wrong -- sorry -- we know right
from wrong, we no
good from evil, we know how to
cure the ills of this
nation -- we need to change
agreed agreed and
selfishness, it has to start
with you.
With you the
individual. You must become,
I must become the industry in
the hands our savor.
Our savor is unselfishness, our
savor is grace and
mercy than the less fortunate
than we are. Our savor
is recognizeing that we are a
family and just as with
your blood families there are
those we don't
particular like.
But if we are to
survive as a family, as a
nation, we must all have the
opportunities to
survive.
We need to trampel
down the
-- to prosper,
to reach his or her greatest
potential or highest
level of productivity, you
deprive yourself of
whatever that person might have
been able or willing
to contribute to the better. Of
man kind.
It amounts to cutting
off your own nose
despite your face.
The Bible says, we
have inherited ability
to hide in our own hearts, we
make our hearts the
breeding ground for sin. That's
an old fashion world
world.
One that we rarely
hear because we are
assignmented to say it.
Most many of us are
not ashameed to do what
it means.
The Bible says you
should know the truth
and the truth will set you free
-- we need to
recognize the truth that you
walk in will set you
free. You need to do what you
know to be right in
order for what you know to set
you free. It's as
we've all been put in prison,
and in order to get
out we must pay basketball,
that's truth. We insists
on staying in jail and not walk
ing in our freedom,
why? Very similarly and very sad
ly because everyone
is doing it.
Nobody has the courage to say
this is
wrong. This is counter
productive, this is not in
our best interest, no one is
willing to recognize
the fact that if we stay on this
path we'll perish.
We're not the blind leading the
blind -- it begins
the criteria for our behaver.
Are we all sheep just
following some leader to
slaughter. The big
difference between us and sheep
we get to choose our
leaders and to -- we must follow
those -- what
criteria are we using to choose
our leaders and are
leaders concerned with to make
their choices, to
create law that's are in the
best interests of us or
even in their own best interests
. Are we also bogged
down what's good for me, what
peels goods to me --
chooseers and chosen
chosen, legitted and electricity
teres, have we
forgotten that we are one nation
undergoes or is is
that no belonger really true?
With you we stopped
saying it other schools, out
loud in other places
have we stopped saying, believe
ing it or wanting it
in our hearts.  Are we so
wrapped up in ourselves
that we're willing to know and
what happenses what's
best for each of us and capeable
of working things
out in a way that we all win.
I know some of you are
thinking I didn't
come here for a sermon, well
when I decided to speak
I didn't intend to give one, I
did want to say
things that would be meaningful
and helpful and call
us all to responsibility. This
is an idea the time
has come again.
The next crop of
leaders in this nation
whether in government, in
corporate America is going
to have the responsibility of
joining the leaders in
helping this nation to fail or
rise or Diane survive
survive, we can survive together
or perish bidefault
because not enough of us care
enough of this nation
together.
Everyone knows you
must care, take care of
and keep from the foundation.
The working class. The
working class is the foundation.
Those that have risen
up have done so
because we have a strong working
class.  We stand on
their shoulders. The creation of
this nation we have
progressed and prospered for
those who are too weak
to fight for themselves.
This is no coincidence deny
dense.
-- a false sense of
security only to be a
aWayne by thoughts from the
outside. We have seen
the end myopathy us.
Another wise man has
quoted what's wrong
with the world -- I am.
If you study the
lessons of seven habits
of highly successful people and
road to character,
you'll learn the lessons
necessary for success.
You're doomed to failure if you
allow your gifts,
tall limits and abilityies to
take you to a place
where your character cannot
sustain you. This apply
applies to a nation as well as
an individual. It's
equally dangerous because it's
arrogance and a flaw
to think you can sustain
accessibility up on good
character even though you allow
that good character
to deteriorate. That is what
that nation has done.
The truth is if you
cannot honestly say
that you've done all you can to
fix what's wrong,
you cannot honestly say it's not
my fault.
I'm not naive enough to think
that this
can happen quickly or even
within the next
generation or two. We need
radical change and it
always calls for revolution. It
will be a task.
While it must be a peaceful
Revelation, it must be
spread thought the nation, not
necessarily to all
but toa larger enough majority
to bring that radical
change, therefore it will be met
with opposition
from those that are so limited
in fore site that
they prefer the status quo. But
every journey begins
with one step and this is the
journey that must
begin. The nation is broken. As
great a task as it
is, as unfair as it is, as young
people say, it is
what it is.
And it is our daunting
task to fix it.
The good news is we
can.
Call me an optimist,
but I believe we can,
but only if enough of us are
ready to take the bull
by the horns, refuse to be self-
indull gent, refuse
to walk in ignorance or
arrogance, we are a family
and we are your brother's keeper
.
We are true to and
persistent about these
things, I promise you as a
people, as a nation, we
will survive.
(APPLAUSE).
Girl.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. Thank you for
bearing
with me through that. But it was
on my heart.
We're backstage, and
Gloria said to me I
have something that I want to
say to folks -- didn't
tell me what it was -- said at
some point that she
was going to share that she want
ed to go to the
podium.
Wow.
Thank you.
To have the courage,
to speak what's in
your heart,
where -- why did you want to do
this?
Where did this come from?
Because if you said you're
not a political person, and it
shoot be seen if you
talk about the challenges that
we're facing that's
all of a sudden you're right,
left, this, that and
the other, we're all humans --
what was it that led
you to say those words?
Well, the
-- this was a speech I was
going
to give in a College, when they
look theeled at it
thecate it 90% of what I said
here, but I felt I
needed to say needed to be said,
when where it came
from, when I was called to speak
I went to my prayer
closet, sat down,
I said I don't know what to say
to
them -- I felt something and I
grab my cell phone
and I put it on dictate and I
began to say -- there
goes an I-Phone -- I began to
say what I heard in my
heart -- and that's -- I didn't
change it -- that's
it.
That's where it came
from.
Right there. God bless
you.
Your story, your words, your
music, who
you are, has been something that
has helped a lot of
people, living your truth as you
have, facing the
challenges that you
lost -- how have you been able
been able to survive?
I survive in that
closet -- I really do --
I take I have everything to God
my faith -- my faith
is very strong. I know God in a
personal way that I
believe he wants to know each
and everyone of us, I
sit down and talk to my daddy --
I say I don't
understand -- I do understand
but I don't like it --
I need help in this -- somebody
else needs help --
my friends -- I would like to do
this with so and so
-- your will be done but please,
can you -- I just
go to him and that's how I
survive everything.
I have this plaque in
my dressing room
that says this too shall pass.
Amen.
That would be good.
Right there on my
remember. Mirror.
As we conclude, a lot
of people, we have
one piece of advice
you can give us to help us --
I follow -- I can only
give you what I have.
I follow one
particular scripture, it's my
favorite scripture, in all my
ways I acknowledge hip
hip, and he addicts my path.
Amen. Gloria Gaynor
ladieses and gentlemen
gentlemen.
(APPLAUSE)
.
She's going to sing.
Don't worry. She's
going to sing.